t1 2 secretary the term secretary means
the secretary of agriculture
section 1108 pandemic ebt
program section 1101 of the family's
first coronavirus response act 7
usc 2011 note public law 116-127
is amended one in subsection a
a by striking during fiscal years 2020
and 2021 and inserting in any school
year in which there is a public health
emergency designation and b
by inserting or in a covered summer
period following a school session
after in session two in subsection g
by striking during fiscal year 2020
the and inserting the three in
subsection
h1 a by inserting either
after at least one child enrolled in
such a covered
child care facility and b by inserting
or a department of agriculture grant
funded nutrition
assistance program in the commonwealth
of the northern mariana islands
puerto rico or american samoa before
shall be eligible to receive
assistance four by redesignating
subsections i
and j as subsections j and k
respectively
five by inserting after subsection h the
following
one emergencies during summer
the secretary of agriculture may permit
a state agency to extend
a state agency plan approved under
subsection b
for not more than 90 days for the
purpose of operating
the plan during a covered summer period
during which time schools participating
in the school lunch program
under the richard b russell national
school lunch act or the school
breakfast program under section 4 of the
child nutrition act of 1966
42 usc 1773
and covered child care facilities shall
be deemed closed
for purposes of this section six
in subsection j as so redesignated a
by redesignating paragraphs two through
six as paragraphs three through seven
respectively
b by inserting after paragraph one the
following
two covered summer period the term
covered summer period means a summer
period that follows a school year during
which there was
a public health emergency designation
and see
in paragraph five as so redesignated by
striking
or another coronavirus with pandemic
potential
and seven in subsection k as so
redesignated
by inserting federal agencies before
state agencies
title ii committee on health education
labor and pensions subtitle a education
matters
part one department of education section
2001
elementary and secondary school
emergency relief fund
a in general in addition to amounts
otherwise available through the
education stabilization fund
there is appropriated to the department
of education for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
one hundred twenty five billion eight
hundred four million
eight hundred thousand dollars to remain
available through september thirtieth
twenty twenty three
to carry out this section b grants
from funds provided under subsection a
the secretary shall make grants to each
state educational agency in accordance
with this section
c allocations to states the amount of
each
grant under subsection b shall be
allocated by the secretary
to each state in the same proportion as
each state received
under part a of title 1 of the
elementary and secondary education act
of 1965
in the most recent fiscal year d sub
grants to local educational agencies
one in general each state shall allocate
not less
than 87.5 percent of the grant funds
awarded
to the state under this section as
subgrants to local
educational agencies including charter
schools
that are local educational agencies in
the state
in proportion to the amounts of funds
such local educational agencies and
charter schools
that our local educational agencies
received under part a
of title 1 of the elementary and
secondary education act of 1965
in the most recent fiscal year
to availability of funds each state
shall make allocations under paragraph 1
to local educational agencies in an
expedited and timely manner
and to the extent practicable not later
than 60 days
after the receipt of such funds e uses
of funds
a local educational agency that receives
funds
under this section one shall reserve not
less than 20 percent
of such funds to address learning loss
through the implementation of
evidence-based interventions
such as summer learning or summer
enrichment extended day
comprehensive after school programs or
extended school year programs
and ensure such interventions respond to
students academic
social and emotional needs and address
the disproportionate impact of the
coronavirus on
the student subgroups described in
section 1111 b2
b11 of the elementary and secondary
education act of 1965
20 usc 6311 b2b
11 students experiencing homelessness
and children and youth in foster care
and
two shall use the remaining funds for
any of the following a any activity
authorized by the elementary and
secondary education act 1965
b any activity authorized by the
individuals with disabilities education
act
c any activity authorized by the adult
education and family literacy act
d any activity authorized by the carl d
perkins career and technical education
act of 2006
e coordination of preparedness and
response efforts of local educational
agencies with state local tribal and
territorial public health departments
and other relevant agencies to improve
coordinated responses among such
entities
to prevent prepare for and respond
activities to address the unique needs
of low-income children or students
children with disabilities english
learners racial and ethnic
minorities students experiencing
homelessness and foster care
youth including how outreach and service
delivery will meet the needs of each
population
g developing and implementing procedures
and systems to improve the preparedness
and response efforts of local
educational agencies age
training and professional development
for state staff of the local educational
agency on sanitation and minimizing the
spread of infectious diseases
i purchasing supplies to sanitize and
clean the facilities of a local
educational agency
including buildings operated by such
agency jay
planning for coordinating and
implementing activities during long-term
closures
including providing meals to eligible
students providing technology for online
learning to all
students providing guidance for carrying
out requirements under the individuals
with disabilities education act and
ensuring other educational services can
continue to be provided consistent with
all federal state and local requirements
k purchasing educational technology
including hardware software and
connectivity for students who are served
by the local educational agency that
aids in regular and substantive
educational interaction between students
and the classroom instructors
including low-income students and
children with disabilities which may
include assistive technology or adaptive
equipment
l providing mental health services and
supports including through the
implementation of evidence-based
full-service community schools and
planning and implementing activities
related to summer
learning and supplemental after-school
programs including providing classroom
instruction or online learning during
the summer
months and addressing the needs of
low-income students
children with disabilities english
learners migrant students
students experiencing homelessness and
children in foster care
and addressing learning loss among
students
including low-income students children
with disabilities
english learners racial and ethnic
minorities students experiencing
homelessness in children
and youth in foster care of the local
educational agency including by
one administering and using high quality
assessments that are
valid and reliable to accurately assess
students
academic progress and assist educators
in meeting students academic needs
including through differentiating
instruction
two implementing evidence-based
activities to meet the comprehensive
needs of students three
providing information and assistance to
parents and families on how
they can effectively support students
including in a distance learning
environment
and four tracking student attendance and
improving student engagement
in distance education oh
school facility repairs and improvements
to enable operation of schools to reduce
risk of virus transmission and exposure
to environmental health hazards and to
support student health needs p
instruction testing maintenance repair
replacement and upgrade projects
to improve the indoor air quality in
school facilities including mechanical
and non-mechanical heating
ventilation and air conditioning systems
filtering
purification and other air cleaning bans
control systems and window and door
repair and replacement
cue developing strategies and
implementing public health protocol
calls including to the greatest extent
practicable policies in line with
guidance from the centers for disease
control and prevention for the reopening
and
operation of school facilities to
effectively maintain the health and
safety of students educators and other
staff
are other activities that are necessary
to maintain the operation of and
continuity
of services and local educational
agencies and continuing to employ
existing staff of the
local educational agency f
state funding with funds not otherwise
allocated under subsection d
estate one shall reserve not less than
five percent of the total amount of
grant funds awarded to the state under
this section to carry out
directly or through grants or contracts
activities to address
learning laws by supporting the
implementation of evidence-based
interventions
such as summer learning or summer
enrichment extended day comprehensive
after-school programs or extended school
year
programs and ensure that such
interventions respond to students
academic social and emotional needs
and address the disproportionate impact
of the coronavirus
on the student subgroups described in
section 1111 b2b
11 of the elementary and secondary
school act of 1965 20 usc
6311 b2 b11 students experiencing
homelessness and children and youth in
foster care including by providing
additional support to local educational
agencies to fully address
such impacts two shall reserve not less
than one percent of the total amount
of grant funds awarded to the state
under this section to carry out directly
or through grants or contracts the
implementation of evidence-based summer
enrichment programs
and ensure such programs respond to
students academic social and emotional
needs and address the disproportionate
impact of the coronavirus
on the student populations described in
section 1111b
2b 11 the elementary and secondary
education act of 1965
20 usc 6311 b2 b11
students experiencing homelessness and
children and youth in foster care
three shall reserve not less than one
percent of the total amount of grant
funds awarded to the state
under this section to carry out directly
or through grants or contracts the
implementation of evidence-based
comprehensive after-school programs and
ensure such programs respond to students
academic social and emotional needs and
address
the disproportionate impact of the
coronavirus on the student populations
described in section
1111b2 b11 of the secondary elementary
and secondary act
of 1965 20 usc 6311b2b11
students experiencing homelessness in
children and youth in foster care
four shall reserve 2.5 of the total
amount of grant funds awarded to the
state under this section to carry out
directly
or through grants or contracts the
purchase of educational technology
including hardware software and
connectivity for students who are served
by the local educational agencies
in that state that aids in regular and
substantive educational interaction
between
students and their classroom instructors
including low-income students and
children with disabilities which may
include assistive technology or adaptive
equipment
and five may reserve not more than
one-half of one percent of the total
amount of grant funds awarded to the
state under the section for
administrative costs and remainder
and the remainder for emergency needs as
determined by the state educational
agency to address
issues responding to coronavirus which
may be addressed through the use of
grants or contracts g reallocation
estate show return to the secretary any
funds received under this section
the state does not award within one year
receiving such funds and the secretary
shall reallocate such funds to the
remaining states in accordance with
subsection c
h definitions in this section one the
terms child children with disabilities
distance education
elementary school english learner
evidence-based secondary school
local educational agency parent
secretary state educational agency
and technology have the meanings given
those terms in section 8
101 of the elementary and secondary
education act of 1965
20 usc 7801 two the term full
service community school has the meaning
given that term in section four six two
two
two of the elementary and secondary
education act of 1965 20 usc 72722
and three the term state means each of
the 50 states the district of columbia
and the commonwealth of puerto rico
section 2002 emergency assistance to
non-public schools a
in general in addition to amounts
otherwise available through the
emergency assistance to non-public
schools program there is appropriated to
the department of education for fiscal
year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise
appropriated two billion seven hundred
fifty million
dollars to remain available through
september thirty twenty twenty three
to make allocations to governors under
the emergency assistance to non-public
schools program
to provide services or assistance to
non-public schools that enroll a
significant percentage of low-income
students that are most impacted by the
qualifying emergency
b limitations funds provided under
subsection a shall not be used to
provide reimbursements to any non-public
school
section 2003 higher education emergency
relief fund
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
department of education for fiscal year
2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 39 billion 584
million 570 000 to remain available
through september 30 2023 to make
allocations to institutions of higher
education in accordance with the same
terms and conditions
of section 314 of the coronavirus
response and relief supplemental
appropriations act 2021 division m of
public law 116-260
except that one subsection a1 upsets
such
section 314 shall be applied by
submitting 91 percent for 89 percent
to subsection a2 of such
section 314 shall be applied a in the
matter preceding
subparagraph a by substituting under the
head heading higher education in the
department of education appropriations
act 2020 for
in the further consolidated
appropriations act 2020 public law
116-94 and b
in some paragraph b by substituting
under the heading higher education
in the department of education
appropriations act 2020 for
in the further consolidated
appropriations act 2020 public law
116-94
three an institution that receives an
allocation apportioned in accordance
with clause three of subsection a to a
of sub such section 314 that has a total
endowment size of less than one million
dollars including an institution that
does not have an endowment
shall be treated by the secretary as
having a total endowment size of one
million dollars for the purposes of such
clause
3. for subsection a4 of such
section 314 shall be applied by
substituting one percent for three
percent
five except as provided in paragraph
seven and nine of subsection d
of such section three one four an
institution shall use a portion of funds
received under the section to a
implement evidence-based practices to
monitor and suppress coronavirus in
accordance with public health guidelines
and b conduct direct outreach to
financial aid applicants
about the opportunity to receive a
financial aid adjustment due the recent
unemployment
of a family member or independent
student or other circumstances described
in section 479a
the higher education act of 1965 20 usc
108 7tt 6 the following shall not apply
to
funds provided or received in accordance
with the section a subsection b of such
section 314 b paragraph 2 of subsection
c of such section 314 c paragraphs 1 2
4 5 6 and 8 of subsection d of such
section 314 d subsections e and
f of such section 314 and e
section 316 of the coronavirus response
and relief
supplemental appropriations acts 2021
division m of public law 116-260 and 7.
an institution that receives an
allocation under this section
apportioned in accordance with
subsection
subparagraphs a through d of subsection
a1
of such section 314 shall not use less
than
50 percent of such allocation to provide
emergency financial aid grants to
students in accordance with subsection
c3 of such
section 314 section 2004 maintenance of
effort and maintenance of equity
a state maintenance of effort one in
general
as a condition of receiving funds under
section 2001 a state shall maintain
support for elementary and secondary
education
and for higher education which shall
include state funding
to institutions of higher education and
state need-based financial aid and shall
not include support for capital projects
or for research and development or
tuition and fees paid by students
in each of fiscal years 2022 and 2022
at least at the proportional levels of
such state support for elementary and
secondary education and for higher
education relative to such states
overall spending
averaged over fiscal years 2017 2018 and
2019.
to waiver for the purpose of relieving
fiscal burdens
incurred by states in preventing
preparing for and responding to the
coronavirus the secretary of education
may waive any maintenance of effort
requirements associated with
the education stabilization fund b state
maintenance of equity
one high need local educational agencies
as the condition of receiving funds
intersection two
two zero zero one a state educational
agency sell not in fiscal years 2022 or
2023
reduce state funding as calculated on a
per-pupil basis for any high-need
local educational agency in the state by
an amount that exceeds the overall
per pupil reduction in state funds if
any
across all local educational agencies in
such state and such fiscal year
two highest poverty local educational
agencies notwithstanding paragraph one
as a condition of receiving funds under
section two zero zero one a state
educational agency shall not
in fiscal year 2022 or 2023 reduce state
funding as calculated on a per-pupil
basis
for any highest poverty local
educational agency belong
below the level of funding as calculated
on a per-pupil basis provided to each
such
local educational agency in fiscal year
2019
c local educational agency maintenance
of equity for high poverty schools one
in general as a condition of receiving
funds under section 2001
a local educational agency saw not in
fiscal year 2022 or 2023 a
reduced per-pupil funding from combined
state and local funding for any high
poverty school served by such a local
educational agency by
an amount that exceeds one the total
reduction in local educational
agency funding from combined state and
local funding for all schools served by
the local educational agency in such
fiscal year if any divided by two
the number of children enrolled in all
schools served by the local educational
agency in such fiscal year or b
reduced per pupil full-time equivalent
staff in any high poverty
school by an amount that exceeds one the
total reduction in full-time equivalent
staff
in all schools served by such local
educational agency and suspicious
year if any divided by two the number of
children enrolled in all schools
served by the local educational agency
in such fiscal year
two exception paragraph one shall not
apply to a local educational agency in
fiscal year 2022 or 2023
that meets at least one of the following
criteria in such fiscal year
a such local educational agency has a
total enrollment of less than 1 000
students
b such local educational agency operates
a single school
c such local educational agency serves
all students
within each grade span with a c with a
single school
d such local educational agency
demonstrates an exceptional or
uncontrollable circumstance such as
unpredictable changes in student
enrollment or precipitous decline in the
financial resources of such agency as
determined by the secretary of education
d definitions in this section one
elementary education secondary education
the terms
elementary education and secondary
education have the meaning given
such terms under state law two highest
poverty local educational agency the
term highest poverty local educational
agency means local educational agency
that is among the group of local
educational agencies in that state that
a
in rank order had the highest
percentages of economically
disadvantaged students in the state on
the basis of the most recent
satisfactory data available from the
department of commerce or
for local educational agencies for which
no such data are available
such other data as the secretary of
education determines are satisfactory
and b
collectively serve not less than 20
percent of the state's total enrollment
of students served by
all local educational agencies in the
state three high need local educational
agencies
the term high need local educational
agency means a local educational agency
that is among the group
of local educational agencies in the
state that a
in rank order have the highest
percentage of economically disadvantaged
students in the state on the basis of
the most recent satisfactory data
available from the department of
commerce or for local educational
agencies for which no such data are
available
such other data as the secretary of
education determines their satisfactory
and b collectively serve not less than
50 percent of the state's total
enrollment of students served by all
local educational agencies in the state
four high poverty school a in general
the term high poverty school means with
respect to a school served by a local
educational agency
a school that is the highest quartile of
schools served by such local educational
agency based on the percentage of
economically disadvantaged students
served as determined by the state in
accordance with subparagraph b b
determination in making the
determination said paragraph a
estate shall select a measure of poverty
established for the purposes of this
paragraph by the secretary of education
and apply such measure
consistently to all schools in the state
five overall per-pupil reduction in
state funds the term overall per
pupil reduction in state funds means
with respect to a fiscal year a
the amount of any reduction in the total
amount of state funds provided to all
local
educational agencies in the state in
such fiscal year compared to the total
amount of such funds provided to all
local educational agencies in the state
in the
previous fiscal year divided by b the
aggregate number of
children enrolled in all schools served
by all local educational agencies in the
state for the fiscal year for which the
determination is being made
six state the term state means each of
the 50 states the district of columbia
and the commonwealth of puerto rico
section 2005 outlying areas in addition
to amounts otherwise available there was
appropriated by the department of
education for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 850 million
dollars to remain available through
september 32 2023 for the secretary of
education to allocate awards to the
outlying
areas on the basis of their respective
needs is determined by the secretary to
be allocated not more than 30 calendar
days after the date of enactment of this
act
section 2006 gallaudet university in
addition to amounts otherwise available
there is appropriated to the department
of education for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated nineteen million
two hundred fifty thousand dollars to
remain available through september
thirty two thousand twenty three for the
kindle demonstration elementary school
the model secondary school for the deaf
and the gallaudet university to prevent
prepare for and respond to coronavirus
including to defray expenses associated
with coronavirus
including lost revenue reimbursement for
expenses already incurred technology
costs associated with the transition to
distance education faculty and staff
trainings and payroll
and to provide financial aid grants to
students which may
be used for any component of the
student's cost of education
section 2007 student administration in
addition to amounts otherwise available
there is appropriated to the department
of education for fiscal year 2021 out of
any money in the treasury not otherwise
appropriated
91 million 130 thousand dollars to
remain available through september 30
2023
for student aid administration within
the department of education to prevent
prepare for and respond to coronavirus
including direct outreach to students
and borrowers about financial aid
economic
impact payments means tested benefits
unemployment assistance and tax benefits
for which the students and borrowers may
be eligible section 2008 howard
university
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
department of education for fiscal year
2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 35 million
dollars to remain available through
september 30 2023
for howard university to prevent prepare
for and respond to coronavirus including
to defray expenses associated with
coronavirus including lost revenue
reimbursement for expenses already
incurred technology costs
facility associated with the transition
to a distance education faculty and
staff trainings
and payroll and to provide financial aid
grants to students which may be used for
any component of the student's cost of
attendance
section 2009's national technology
technical institute for the deaf in
addition to amounts otherwise available
there is appropriated to the department
of education for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in treasury not
otherwise appropriated 19 million 250
thousand dollars to remain available
through september 30 2023
for the national technical institute for
the deaf to prevent prepare for and
respond to coronavirus
including to defray expenses associated
with coronavirus including lost revenue
reimbursement for expenses already
incurred technology costs associated
with the transition to distance
education
faculty and staff training and payroll
and to provide financial aid grants to
students which may be used for any
component of the student's cost
of attendance section
2010 institute for educational sciences
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
department of education for fiscal year
2021 out of any money in the treasury
not otherwise appropriated
100 million dollars to remain available
through september 30 2023
for the institute of education sciences
to carry out research related
to addressing learning loss caused by
the coronavirus
among the student subgroups described in
section 111
1b2b11 of the elementary and secondary
education act of 1965 20 usc
6311 b2 b11 and the students
experiencing homelessness in children
and youth in foster care
and to disseminate such findings to
state educational agencies and local
educational agencies and other
appropriate entities
section 2011 program administration in
addition to amounts otherwise available
there is appropriated to the department
of education for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriate 15 million
to remain available through september
30th 2024 for program administration
within the department of education to
prevent prepare for and respond to
coronavirus
and for salaries and expenses necessary
to implement this part
section 2012 office of inspector general
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
department of education for fiscal year
2021 out of any money in the treasury
not otherwise appropriate five million
dollars remain available until
expended for the office of inspector
general of the department of education
for salaries and expenses necessary for
oversight
investigations and audits of programs
grants and project
projects funded under this part carried
out by the office of inspector general
section 2 2013 modification of revenue
requirements for proprietary
institutions of higher education
a in general section 487
a 224 of the higher education act of
1965
20 usc 1094 a 24 is amended by striking
funds provided under this title and
inserting funds federal funds that are
dispersed or delivered to
or on behalf of a student to be used by
to attend such institution referred to
in this paragraph in sub-section d
as federal education assistance funds b
implement
implementation of non-federal revenue
requirements section 487d
of the higher education act of 1965. 20
usc
1094-d is amended one in the subsection
heading by striking non-title
iv and inserting non-federal and ii in
paragraph 1c by striking funds for a
program under this title and inserting
federal education assistance funds
part 2 miscellaneous section 2021
national endowment for the arts
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated for
fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 135 million
dollars to remain available until
expended
under the national foundation on the
arts and the humanities
of 1965 as follows one 40 percent shall
be for grants and
relevant administrative expenses to
state art agencies and regional arts
organizations
that support organizations programming
and general operating expenses to cover
up to a hundred percent of the cost
of the program which the grants support
to prevent prepare for respond to and
recover from the coronavirus
two sixty percent shall be for direct
grants and relevant administrative
expenses that support organizations
programming and general operation
expenses to cover up to 100 percent of
the cost of the programs
which the grants support to prevent
prepare for respond to and recover from
the coronavirus
section 2022 national endowment for the
humanities
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated for
fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 135 million
dollars to remain available until
expended under the national foundation
on the arts and the humanities act
of 1965 as follows one forty percent
shall be for grants and relevant
administrative expenses
to state humanities councils that
support humanities organizations
programming
and general operating expenses to cover
up to 100 percent of the cost of the
programs
which the grants support to prevent
prepare for respond to and recover from
the coronavirus
two sixty percent shall be for direct
grant and relevant administrative
expenses the
expenses that support humanities
organizations programming
and general operating expenses to cover
up to 100 percent of the cost of the
programs which the grants support
to prevent prepare for response to
recover from the coronavirus
section 2023 institute of museum and now
library services
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriate to the
institute of museum and library
services for fiscal year 2021 out of any
money in the treasury not otherwise
appropriate
200 million dollars to remain available
until expended for necessary expenses to
carry out museum and library services
the director of the institute of museum
and library services shall award not
less than 89
of such funds to state library
administrative agencies by applying the
formula
in section 221b of the museum and
library services act
except that one section 221b3a of such
acts shall be applied by substituting
two million dollars for 680 thousand
dollars and by substituting two hundred
thousand dollars
for sixty thousand dollars and two
section two two one b
three c and sub sections b and c of
section two two three of such acts shall
not apply to funds provided under this
section
subtitle b labor matters section 2101
funding for department of labor worker
protection activities a appropriation
in addition to amounts otherwise made
available out of any funds in the
treasury not otherwise appropriated
they're appropriated to the secretary
of labor for fiscal year 2021 200
million dollars to remain available
until september 30th 2023 for the wage
and hour division
an office of workers compensation
programs the office of solicitor
the mine safety and health
administration and the occupational
safety and health
administration to carry out covet 19
related worker protection activities
and for the office of inspected
inspector general for oversight of the
secretary's activities to prevent
prepare for and respond to covet 19
b allocation of amounts amounts
appropriated under subsection a shall be
allocated as follows
one not less than 100 million dollars
shall be for the occupational safety and
health administration
of which 10 million shall be for the
susan harwood training grants
and not less than 5 million dollars
should be for enforcement activities
related to covet 19 at high-risk
workplaces including health care
meat and poultry processing facilities
agricultural workplaces and correctional
facilities
too 12 million 500 000 shall be for the
office of the inspector general subtitle
c human services and community supports
section 2201 child care and development
block grant program
a child care and development block grant
funding in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriate for
fiscal year 2021 out of any amounts in
the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 14 billion 990
million
dollars to remain available through
september 30th 2021 to carry out the
program
authorized under section 5658c of the
child care and development block grant
act of 1990.
42 usc 9858 a without regard to
requirements in sections
658ec3e or 658g
of such acts 42 usc 95
58 c c 3 e
9 8 5 8 e
payments made to states territories
indian tribes and tribal organizations
from funds
made available under the subsection
shall be obligated to fiscal year 2021
or the succeeding two fiscal years
states territories indian tribes and
tribal organizations are authorized to
use such funds to provide child care
assistance to health care sector
employees
emergency responders sanitation workers
and other workers deemed essential
during the response to coronavirus
by public officials without regard to
the income eligibility requirements of
section
658 p 4 of this child care and
development block grant act
42 usc 9858 and 4.
the administration administrative cost
in addition to
amounts otherwise available there is
appropriated for fiscal year 2021 out of
any amounts in the treasury not
otherwise appropriate
created 35 million remain available
through september 30th 2025 for the cost
of providing technical assistance and
conducting research
and for the administrative costs to
carry out the section section 2202 of
the subtitle
section 2202 child care stabilization
a definitions in the section 1 coven 19
public health emergency
the term covered 19 public health
emergency means the public health
emergency declared by the secretary of
health and human services
under section 319 of the public health
service act 42 usc
4247d on january 31st 2020 with respect
to coven 19 including any
renewal of this declaration to eligible
child care provider
the term eligible child care provider
means a an eligible child care provider
as defined in section 65 a p of the
child care and developmental
development block grant act of 1990 42
usc
9858n or b a childcare provider that is
licensed regulated or registered in the
state territory or indian tribe on the
date of enactment of this act
it meets applicable state and local
health and safety requirements
b child care stabilization funding in
addition to amounts otherwise available
there is appropriated for fiscal year
2021
out of any amounts in the treasury not
otherwise appropriate
23 billion 975 million
to remain available through september 30
of 2021 for grants under the section in
accordance with the child care and
development
block grant act of 1990. c grants
from the amount amounts appropriated to
carry out the section under the
authority of the section
6580 of the child care and development
block grant act of 1990 42 usc
9858 m and this section the secretary
shall award to such lead agency a child
care stabilization grant
without regard to the requirements in
subparagraph c and e of section
6 5 8 e c 3 and in section 6 658g of the
childcare and development
block grant act of 1990 42 usc 9858
cc39858e
such grant shall be allotted in
accordance with section 6580 of the
child care and development
block grant act of 1990 42 usc 9858
m d state rep reservations and subgrants
one reservation a lead agency for a
state that receives a child care
stabilization grant pursuant to
subsection c shall reserve not more than
10 percent of such grant funds to
administer sub-grants
provide technical assistance and support
for applying for and accessing
the sub-grant opportunity publicize the
availability of the sub-grants carry out
activities to increase the supply of
child care
and provide technical assistance to help
child care providers implement policies
as described in paragraph
two d one two sub grants to qualified
child care providers
a in general the lead agency shall use
the remainder of the grant funds
awarded pursuant to subsection c to make
sub grants to qualified child care
providers
described in some paragraph b regardless
of such a provider's previous receipt of
other federal assistance to support the
stability of the child care sector
during
and after the co-19 public health
emergency b qualified child care
provider
to be qualified to receive a sub grant
under this paragraph a provider shall be
an eligible child care provider that on
the date of the submission of an
application for the subgrant was either
one open and available to provide child
care services or two
closed due to public health financial
hardships or other reasons relating to
the covenant 19
public health emergency c sub grant
amount the amount of such a sub grant to
a qualified child care provider shall be
based on the providers stated current
operating expenses
including costs associated with
providing or preparing to provide child
care services during the 2019
public health emergency and to the
extent practical practical
cover sufficient operating expenses to
ensure continuous operations for the
intended period of the subgrant
d application the lead agency shall one
make available on the lead
agency's website an application for
qualified child care providers that
includes certifications that for the
duration of the sub grant one
the provider applying will when open and
available to provide child
care services implement policies in line
with guidance from the corresponding
state tribal and local authorities
and in accordance with state tribal
local orders and to the greatest extent
possible
implement policies in line with guidance
from the centers for disease control and
prevention
two for each employee the provider will
pay not less than the full compensation
including any benefits that was provided
to the employee as the data submission
for the application for the subgrant
referred to in the sub-clause
as full compensation and will not take
any action that reduces the weekly
amount of the employee's compensation
below the weekly amount of full
compensation
or that reduces the employee's rate of
compensation below the rate of full
compensation
including the involuntary furloughing of
any employee on the date of submission
of the application of the subgrant and
three the provider will provide relief
from co-payments and tuition payments
for the families enrolled in the
providers program
to the extent possible and prioritize
each relief for families struggling to
make either
type of payment and two accept and
process applications submitted under the
subparagraph on a rolling basis and
provide subgrant funds
and advance up provider expenditures
except as provided in subsection
e2 e obligation
the lead agency shall notify the
secretary but is unable to obligate at
least 50 percent of the funds received
pursuant to subsection
c that are available for subgrants
described in this paragraph within nine
months of the date of enactment of this
act
e use of funds one in general a
qualified child care provider that
receives funds through such a sub grant
shall use the funds for at least one of
the following a
personal cost and personnel costs
including payroll and salaries or
similar compensation for an employee
including any sole proprietor or
independent contractor employee benefit
premium payer cost for employee
recruitment and retention
b rent including rent under a lease
agreement or payment under any mortgage
mortgage obligation
utilities facility management or
improvements or insurance
c personal protective equipment cleaning
and sanitation supplies and services or
training and professional development
related to health and safety practices
d purchases of or updates to equipment
and supplies to respond to the coven 19
public health emergency
e goods and services necessary to
maintain or resume
child care services f mental health
support for children and employees
two reimbursement the qualified child
care provider may use the sub grant
funds to reimburse the provider for some
obligated or expended before the date of
enactment of this act for the cost of a
good or service described in paragraph
one
to respond to the coven 19 public health
emergency f supplement nut supplement
amounts made available to carry out this
sub section shall be used to supplement
and
supplant other federal state and local
public funds expended to private
to provide child care services for
eligible individuals
section 2203 head start in addition to
amounts otherwise available there's an
appropriate
there is appropriated for fiscal year
2021 out of any amounts in the treasury
not otherwise appropriated
one billion dollars to remain available
through september 30 of 2022 to carry
out the head start act including the
federal administrative
expenses after reserving funds for
federal administrative expenses the
secretary shall allocate all remaining
amounts to head start agencies for
one-time grants and shall allocate to
each headstart agency an amount that
bears the same ratio for the
portion available for allocations as a
member of enrolled children served by
the head start agency bears to the name
to the number of enrolled children
served by all head start agencies
section 2204 programs for survivors a
in general section 303 of the family
violence professions and services act
42 usc 10403 is amended by adding to
at the end of the following d additional
funding for the purposes of carrying out
this title in addition to amounts
otherwise made available for such
purposes
there are appropriated out of any
amounts of the treasury not otherwise
appropriated for the fiscal year 2021 to
remain available until expended
except as otherwise provided in this
subsection each of the following
180 million dollars to carry out the
sections 301 through 312
to be allocated in the manner described
in some section a2 except that a
a reference to in subsection a2 to an
amount appropriate under subsection a1
shall be considered to be a reference to
an amount appropriate under this
paragraph
b the matching requirement in section
306
c4 and the condition in section 308 d3
shall not apply and see
each reference in section 305e to the
end of the following fiscal year
shall be considered to be a reference to
the end of the fiscal year 2025 and d
funds made available to the state no
grant under section 306a and obligated
in a timely manner
shall be available for expenditure by
the state or recipient of funds for the
grant through the end of fiscal year
2025
to 18 million dollars to carry out
section 309
three two million dollars to carry out
section 313 of which one million dollars
shall be allocated for
to support indian communities b coven 19
public health emergency defined in this
section the term
cova 19 public health emergency means a
public health emergency declared by the
secretary of health and human services
under section 319
of the public health service act 42 usc
247 d on january 31st 2020 with respect
to cover 19
including any renewal of the declaration
c
grants support culturally specific
populations
one in general in addition to amounts
otherwise made available there is
appropriate
out of any amounts in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated to the secretary
of human
health and human services in this
section referred to as the secretary
49 million dollars 549 million 500
000 for fiscal year 2021 to be available
until expended to carry out the
subsection including
excluding federal administrative costs
for which funds are appropriate
under subsection e 2 use of funds from
amounts appropriated under paragraph one
the secretary acting through the
director of the family violence
prevention service act
services program shall a support
culturally specific community-based
organizations to provide culturally
specific activities for survivors
of sexual assault and domestic violence
to address emergent needs resulting from
the covenant 19 public health emergency
and other public health concerns and b
support culturally specific
community-based organizations that
provide culturally specific
activities to promote strategic
partnership development and
collaboration in response to the impact
of coping 19
and other public health concerns on
survivors of sexual assault and domestic
abuse
d grants to support survivors of sexual
assault one in general
in addition to the amounts otherwise
made available there is appropriate out
of any amounts in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated to the secretary
198 million dollars for fiscal year 2021
to be available until expended to carry
out in the subsection
excluding federal administrative costs
for which funds are appropriate under
subsection
e 2 use of funds per month from amounts
appropriate under paragraph one
secretary acting through the director of
the family violence prevention and
services program
shall assist rape crisis centers in
transitioning to virtual services and
meet
meeting them emergency needs of
survivors e administrative costs in
addition to the amounts otherwise made
available there is an appropriate to the
senate
to the secretary other out of any uh
amounts in the treasury not otherwise
appropriated 2 million 500 000 for the
fiscal year 2021 to remain available
until expended
the federal administrative costs of
carrying out subsections
c and d section 2 2205 child abuse
abuse prevention and treatment in
addition to amounts otherwise available
there is appropriated to the secretary
of health and human services for fiscal
year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriate the following
amounts to remain available through
september 30 of 2023
one 250 million dollars for um
carrying out the program authorized
under section 201 of the child abuse
prevention and treatment act 42 usc
5116 while shall be allocated without
regard to section
204 of such act 42 usc 5116 d4 and shall
be
allotted to states in accordance with
section 203 of such act 42 usc
51 16b except that a and sub section b
1 a of such section 2 or 3 70 shall be
deemed to be 100 and b
sub sections b 1 b and c of such section
2 or 3 shall not apply and 2
100 million dollars for carrying out the
state grant program authorized under
section 106 of the child abuse
prevention and treatment act 42 usc 5106
a which shall be allocated without
regard to section
1 1 2 a 2 such act 42 usc
5106 ha2 section 2206 corporation
for national and community service in
the national service trust a corporation
for national and community service in
addition to amounts otherwise made
available there is appropriated for
fiscal year 2021 out of any money in the
treasury
not otherwise appropriated to the
corporation for national and community
services
852 million dollars to remain available
through september 30th 2024 to carry out
subsection b
except the amounts to carry out
subsection b7 shall remain available
until september 30th 2026
the allocation of amounts amounts
provided by subsection a shall be
allocated as follows
one americorps state and national 620
million dollars shall be used a to
increase the living allowances of
participants in national service
programs and b
to make funding adjustments to existing
as of the date of the enactment of this
act awards and award new and additional
awards to
entities to support programs described
in paragraphs 1b 2b 3b 4b and phibia
subsection a
and subsection b2 of section 122 of the
national community service act of 1990
42 usc 125.72 whether
or not that entities are already grant
recipients under such provisions
on the day of enactment of this act and
notwithstanding section 122 a1b
6 of the national community service act
of 1990 42 usc
one two five seven two a one b six five
one
prioritizing entities serving
communities disproportionately impact by
cover 19
and utilizing culturally competent and
multilingual strategies and provisions
of services and
to taking into account the diversity of
communities and participants served by
such entities
including racial ethnic socioeconomic
linguistic and geographic diversity to
state commissions 20 million dollars
shall be used to make adjustments to
just
existing as of the date of the enactment
of this act awards and
awards and new and additional awards
including awards the state commission on
national community service
under section 126a of the national
community service act of 1990
42 usc 125 76a
three volunteer generation fund 20
million shall be used for expenses
authorized under section 501 a4
f of the national and community service
act of 1990 42 usc 126 81a
4f which not withstanding section 198p
d1b of that act 42 usc 126
653 pd 1b shall be for grants awarded to
the corporation for national and
community service
on a competitive basis for americorps
vista
80 million shall be used for the
purposes described in section 101 of the
domestic
volunteer service act of 1973 42 usc
4951
including to increase the living
allowances of volunteers described in
section 105b of domestic
volunteer service act of 1973 42 usc
4955b
five national senior service corps
thirty million dollars shall be used for
the purposes described in section two
under the domestic violence service act
of 1973
42 usc 5000 six administration
administrative calls 73 million shall be
used for the corporation for national
and community service for administrative
expenses
to carry out programs and activities
funded first by subsection a
seven office of inspector general nine
million dollars shall be used for the
office of inspector general for the
corporation for national and community
services for salaries and expenses
necessary for oversight and audit
of programs and activities funded by
subsection a c national service trust in
addition to amounts
otherwise made available there is
appropriated for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriate 148 million
dollars to remain available until
expended for administration of the
national
service russian for payments of the
trust for the provision of educational
awards pursuant to section 145
a 1a of the national community service
act of 1990 42 usc
12601a1a
subtitled d public health section 2301
funding for covet 19 vaccine activities
at the centers for disease control and
prevention
a in general in addition to the amounts
otherwise available there is
appropriated to the secretary of health
and human services
in this subtitle referred to as the
secretary for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
seven billion five hundred million
dollars to remain available until
expended to carry out activities
to plan prepare for promote distribute
administer and monitor and track coven
19 vaccines
79 b use of funds the secretary
acting through the director of the
centers for disease control and
prevention
and in consultation with other agencies
as applicable shall in conducting
activities referred to in subsection a
one conduct activities to enhance expand
and improve
nationwide covet 19 vaccine distribution
and administration including activities
related to the distribution of ancillary
medical products and supplies related to
vaccines
and two provide technical assistance
guidance
and support to and award grants or
cooperative agreements to state
local tribal and territorial public
health departments
for enhancement of covet 19 vaccine
distribution
and administration capabilities
including a
the distribution and administration of
vaccines license under section 351 of
the public health service act
42 usc 262 or authorized under section
564 of the federal
food drug and cosmetic act 21 usc 360
bbb3
and ancillary medical products and
supplies related to vaccines
b the establishment expansion including
staffing support of community
vaccination centers particularly in
underserved areas see the deployment of
mobile vaccination units particularly in
underserved areas
d information technology standards-based
data and reporting enhancements
including improvements necessary to
support
standards-based sharing of data related
to vaccine distribution
in vaccine systems that enhance vaccine
safety effectiveness and uptake
particularly among underserved
populations
e facility enhancements f communication
with the public regarding when where
and how to receive covid 19 vaccines and
g
transportation of individuals to
facilitate vaccinations including at
community vaccination centers and mobile
vaccination units
particularly for underserved populations
c supplemental funding for state
vaccination grants
one definitions in the subsection a base
formula the term based formula means
the allocation of formula that applied
to the public health emergency
preparedness cooperative agreement
fiscal year
2020 b alternative allocation the term
alternative allocation means an
allocation to each state
territory or locality calculating use
the percentage derived from the
allocation received by such state
territory or locality
of the aggregate amount of fiscal year
2020 public health emergency
preparedness cooperative agreement
awards under section
319 c1 of the public health service act
42 usc 247 t3a two supplemental funding
a in general
not later than 21 days after the date of
the enactment of this act
the secretary shall use amounts
described in subsection a to provide
supplemental funding to any state
locality or territory
that received less of the amounts that
were appropriated under title iii of
division m of public law
one one six two six zero for vaccination
grants to be issued by the centers of
disease control and prevention then such
state locality or territory would have
received had such
amounts been allocated using the
alternative allocation b amount
the amount of supplemental funding
provided under this subsection shall be
equal to the amount between one
the amount of state locality or
territory received or would receive
under the base formula and two the
amount of state locality or territory
will receive under the alternative
allocation section 2302 funding for
vaccine confidence activities
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
secretary for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
one billion dollars to remain available
until expended and carry out activities
acting through the director of the
centers for disease control and
prevention
one to strengthen vaccine confidence in
the united states including its
territories and possessions
two to provide further information and
education with respect to vaccines
license under section
351 of public health cervix act 42 usc
262 are authorized under section 564
of the federal drug and cosmetic act 21
usc 360 bbb
3 and 3 to improve rates of vaccination
throughout the united states including
its territories and possessions
including through activities described
in section 313 of the public health
service act
as amended by section 311 of division bb
of the consolated appropriations act
2021 public law 116-260
section 2303 funding for supply chain
for cova 19 vaccines therapeutics and
medical supplies
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
secretary for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
six billion fifty million dollars to
remain available until expended for
necessary expenses with respect to
research development
manufacturing production and purchases
of vaccines therapeutics
and ancillary medical products supplies
to prevent prepare and respond to
sars cov2 or any very viral variant
mutating their form with the pandemic
potential and two covet 19 or any
disease with potential to create a
pandemic
section 2304 funding for covet 19
vaccine therapeutic
and device activities at the food and
drug administration
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
secretary for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
500 million dollars to remain available
until expended
to be used for evaluation of the
continued performance safety and
effectiveness
including with respect to emerging
coveted 19 variants of vaccines
therapeutics and diagnostics approved
cleared license or authorized for use
for treatment
prevention or diagnosis of covet 19
facilitation of advanced continuous
manufacturing activities related to the
production of vaccine
and related materials facilitation and
conduct inspections related to the
manufacturing of vaccines
therapeutics and devices delayed or
cancelled for reasons related to covet
19 review of devices authorized for use
for the treatment prevention or
diagnosis of covid19
and oversight of the supply chain and
mitigation of shortages
of vaccines therapeutics and devices
approved cleared licensed or authorized
for use for the treatment prevention or
diagnosis of covid19 by the food and
drug administration
section 2305 reduced cost sharing a
in general section 1402 of the patient
protection and affordable care act is
amended
by redesignating subsection f and
subsection g
and by inserting after subsection e the
following new subsection
f special rule for individuals who
receive unemployment compensation during
2021
for purposes of this section in the case
of an individual who has received or has
been approved to receive
unemployment compensation for any week
beginning
during 2021 for the plan year in which
such week begins
one such individual shall be treated as
meeting the requirements of subsection b
two and two for the purposes of
subsection c
and d they shall not be taken into
account any household income or
individual in excess of 133 percent of
the poverty line
for a family of the size involved b
effective date the amendment made by
this section shall apply to plein years
beginning after december 31st
2020. subtitle e testing
section 2401 funding for covet 19
testing contact tracing and mitigation
activities
a in general in addition to amounts
otherwise available there is
appropriated to the secretary of health
and human services
in the subtitle referred to as secretary
for fiscal year 2021 out of any money in
the treasury
not otherwise appropriated 47
billion 800 million dollars to remain
available until expended
to carry out activities to detect
diagnose
trace and monitor sars cov2 and covet 19
infections and related strategies
to mitigate the spread of coven 19 be
use of funds from amounts
the secretary shao won implement a
national
evidence-based strategy for testing
conduct tracing
surveillance and mitigation with respect
to sars cov2
and covet 19 including through
activities authorized under section 319a
of the public health service act two
provide technical assistance guidance
and support
and award grants for cooperative
agreements to state local and
territorial
public health departments for activities
to detect diagnose trace and monitor
sars cov2 and cova 19 infections and
related strategies and activities to
mitigate the spread of coven 19.
three support the development
manufacturing procurement distribution
and administration
of tests to detect or diagnose sars kobe
2 and covet 19
including through a support for the
development manufacture
procurement and distribution of supplies
necessary for administering tests such
as personal protective equipment and b
support for the acquisition construction
alteration or renovation
of non-federally owned facilities for
the production of diagnostics and
ancillary medical products and supplies
where the secretary determines
that such an investment is necessary to
ensure the production of sufficient
amount of such supplies for establish
and expand
federal state local and territorial
testing contact tracing capabilities
including a through investments in
laboratory capacity such as
one academic and research laboratories
or other laboratories that could be used
for processing
of cover 19 testing two community-based
testing sites and community-based
organizations or three
mobile health units particularly in
medically underserved areas and b
with respect to quarantine and isolation
of contacts five enhanced information
technology
data modernization and reporting
including improvements necessary to
support
sharing data related to public health
capabilities six
award grants to or enter in cooperative
agreements or contracts with
state local and territorial public
health departments to establish expand
and sustain a public health workforce
and seven to cover administrative and
program supports
costs necessary to conduct activities
related to subcarrier f a
section 2402 funding for stars co v2
genomic sequencing and surveillance a in
general addition to amounts otherwise
available
there is appropriated to the secretary
for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
1 billion 750 million dollars to remain
available until expended to strengthen
and expand activities
workforce related genomic sequencing and
analytics and disease surveillance
the use of funds from amounts
appropriated by subsection a the
secretary acting through the director of
the centers for the disease control and
prevention shall
one conduct expand and improve
activities to sequencing genomes
identify mutations and survey the
circulation and transmission
of viruses and other organisms including
strains of stars cov2
two award grants or cooperative
agreements state local tribal or
territorial public health departments or
public health laboratories a
to increase their capacity to sequence
genomes of circulating strains of
viruses and other organisms including
sars kobe 2 b to identify mutations and
viruses and other organisms including
stars code v2
c to use genomic sequencing to identify
outbreaks and clusters of disease and
infections including cova 19 and d to
develop effective disease response
strategies
based on genomic sequencing and
surveillance data
three enhance and expand the
informatics capabilities of the public
health workforce
and four award grants for the
construction alteration or renovation
facilities to improve genomic sequencing
and surveillance capabilities
at the state and local level section
2403 funding for global health
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
secretary for fiscal year 2021
out of any amounts in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 750 million
dollars to remain available until
expended for activities to be conducted
acting through the director of centers
for disease control prevention of combat
of stars kobe 2 of 19 and other emerging
infectious diseases threats globally
including efforts related to global
health security global disease detection
and response
global health protection global
immunization global coordination and
public health
section 2404 funding for data
modernization and forecasting center
in addition to the amounts otherwise
available there was appropriated to the
secretary for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 500 million
remain available until expended for
activities to be conducted acting
through the director of the centers for
disease control and prevention to
support public health data surveillance
and analytics
infrastructure modernization initiative
and the centers for disease control and
presentation
and establish expand and maintain
efforts to modernize the united states
disease warning system to forecast and
track hot spots
covered 19 its variants and emerging
biological threats including academic
workforce support for analytics and
informatics infrastructure and data
collection systems
subtitle f public health workforce
section 2501 funding for public health
workforce
a in general in addition to amounts
otherwise available there is
appropriated to the
secretary of health and human services
in the subtitle referred to as the
secretary
for fiscal year 2021 have any money in
the treasury not otherwise appropriated
7 billion 660 million dollars to remain
available until expended to carry out
activities
relating to establishing expanding and
sustaining a public health workforce
including by making awards to state
local and territorial public health
departments
b use of funds for public health
determines amounts made available to an
awardee pursuant to subsection a
shall be used for the following
one costs including wages and benefits
related to the recruiting hiring and
training of individuals
a to serve as case investigators contact
tracers
social support specialists community
health workers public health nurses
disease intervention specialists
epidemiologists program managers
laboratory personnel
informaticians communications and policy
experts in any other position as may be
required to prevent prepare for and
respond to coba 19 and b who are
employed by
one the state territorial or local
public health department involved or
two a non-profit private or public
organization with demonstrated expertise
in implementing public health programs
and establish relationships with such
state territorial or local public health
departments
particularly in medically underserved
areas to personal protective equipment
data management and other technology or
other necessary
supplies three administrative costs
and activities necessary for awardees to
implement activities funded under this
section
four sub-awards from recipients of
awards under subsection a to local
health departments for the purpose of
activities funded under this section
section 2502 funding for medical reserve
corps in addition to the amounts
otherwise available there is
appropriated to the secretary for fiscal
year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
100 million dollars to remain available
until expended for carrying out section
2
2813 of the public health service act 42
usc
300 h-15 subtitle g public health
investments
section 2601 funding for community
health centers and community care
a in general in addition to amounts
otherwise available there is
appropriated to the secretary of health
and human services
and this subtitle referred to as the
secretary for fiscal year 2021 out of
any money in the treasury not otherwise
appropriated
7 billion 600 million dollars to remain
available until expended for necessary
expenses
for awarding grants and cooperative
agreements under section 330 of the
public health service act
42 usc 254b to be awarded regard to the
time
limitation subsection e3 and subsections
e
6 a 3 e 6 b 3
and r 2 b of subsection 3
0 and for necessary expenses for
awarding grants
to federally qualified health centers as
described in sections
1861 aaa 4b of the social security act
42 usc 1395
xaa4b and four awarding grants or
contracts
to papa ola lakani and two qualified
entities
under section four and six of the native
hawaiian health care improvement act
42 usc 11703-11705
of the total amount appropriated by the
preceding sentence
not less than 20 million dollars shall
be grants or
contracts to papa ola and to qualified
entities under section four and six of
the native hawaiian health improvement
act
42 usc 117031705
the use of funds amounts made available
to an rd pursuant to subsection a shall
be used one
to plan prepare for promote distribute
administer and track cover 19 vaccines
and to carry out other vaccine-related
activities
two to detect diagnose trace and monitor
cova-19 infections and related
activities necessary to mitigate the
spread of kova 19
including activities related to and
equipment or supplies purchased for
testing contact tracing surveillance
mitigation
and treatment of coven 19.
three to purchase equipment and supplies
to conduct mobile testing or
vaccinations for covet 19 to purchase
and maintain mobile vehicles equipment
to conduct
such testing or vaccinations and to hire
and train laboratory personnel and other
staff
to conduct such mobile testing or
vaccinations particularly in medically
underserved areas
four to establish expand and sustain the
health care workforce to prevent prepare
for and respond to kova 19
and to carry out other health workforce
related activities
five to modify enhance and expand health
care services and infrastructure
and six to conduct community outreach
and education activities
related to covet 19 c past expenditures
an awardee may use amounts awarded
pursuant to subsection a to cover the
cost of the awardee carrying out
any activity described in subsection b
during the period beginning on the date
of
declaration of the public health
emergency by the secretary under section
319 of public health service act
42 usc 247-d on january 31st 2020
with respect to cover 19 and any on the
date of such award
section 2602 funding for national health
service corps
a in general in addition to the amounts
otherwise available there is
appropriated to the secretary
for fiscal year 2021 out of any money in
the treasury not otherwise appropriated
800 million dollars to remain available
until expended for carrying out sections
338 a 338 b 338i
of the public health service act 42 usc
254 l
five four l one two five q one with
respect to the health workforce
b state loan repayment programs one in
general
of the amount made available pursuant to
section a one hundred million dollars
shall be made available for providing
primary health services through the
grants to states under section 338ia of
the public health service act
42 usc 254 q1 a
two conditions with respect to grants
described in paragraph one using funds
made available under such paragraph
a section 338 ib of the public health
service act
42 usc 254 q1b shall not apply
b notwithstanding section 338 id2 of the
public health service act 42 usc
254q1 d2 not more than 10 percent in a
board to estate from such amounts may be
used
by the state for cost of administering
the state loan repayment program
section 2603 funding for nurse corps in
addition to the amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
secretary for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 200 million
dollars to remain available until
expended for carrying out section
846 of the public health service act 42
usc 297n
section 2604 funding for the teaching
health centers that operate graduate
medical education a in general
in addition to amounts otherwise
available and not withstanding the
capped amount referenced in subsections
three four o h b two and three four o h
d
two of the public health service act
forty two usc two five six hb two
and d two there was appropriated to the
secretary for fiscal year 2021 out of
any money in the treasury not otherwise
appropriated
330 million dollars to remain available
until september 30th 2023 for the
program of payments teaching health
centers
that operate graduate medical education
under subsection 3408 of the public
health service
act 42 usc 256h and for teaching health
center development grants
authorized under section 749a of the
public health service act
42 usc 29 1
b use of funds amounts available
pursuant to subsection a shall be used
for the following activities
one for making payments to establish new
approved graduate medical residency
training programs pursuant to section
340h
a1c of the public health service act 42
usc 256ha1c
two to provide an increase to the per
resident amount described in sections
34082 of the public health service act
42 usc h82 of
ten thousand dollars three for making
payments under section three four zero h
a one a of the public health service act
42 usc 256 ha1a
to qualify teaching health centers for
maintenance of filled positions at
existing approved
graduate medical residency training
programs
four for making payments under section
3408
a1b of the public health service act
42 usc 256 a1b
for the expansion of approved graduate
medical residency training programs
five for making awards under section 749
a
of the public health service act 42 usc
293
l1 to teaching health centers for the
purpose of establishing
new accredited or expanded primary care
residency programs
six to cover administrative costs and
activities necessary
for qualified teaching health centers
receiving payments under section
3408 of the public health service act 42
usc 256h to carry out activities under
such
section section 2605 funding for family
planning
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
secretary for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
50 million dollars to remain available
until expended for necessary expenses
for making grants and contracts under
section 1001 of the public health
service act 42 usc 300
subtitle h mental health and substance
use disorder
section 2701 funding for block grants
for community mental health services
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
secretary of health and human services
in the subtitle referred to as the
secretary for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
1 billion 500 million dollars to remain
available
until expended for carrying out subpart
1
of part b of title 19 of the public
health service act 42 usc
300x subpart 3 of part b of title 19
of such act 42 usc 300x 51
in section 505c of such act 42 usc
290aa-4c with respect to mental health
notwithstanding section 1952 of the
public health service act 42 usc 3x62
any amount awarded to a state out of
amounts appropriated by this section
shall be expended by the state by
september 30th 2025
section 2702 funding for block grants
for prevention and treatment of
substance abuse
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
secretary for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
1 billion 500 million dollars to remain
available until expended
for carrying out subpart 2 of part b of
title 19
of the public health service act 42 usc
300 x
21 subpart 3 of part b of title 19 of
such act
42 usc 300 x 51 section 505 d
of such act 42 usc 290aaa 41d
with respect to substance abuse in
section 515d
of such act 42 usc 290 bb-21d
notwithstanding section 1952 of the
public health service act
42 usc 300x-62 any amount of word to a
state out of amounts
appropriated by this section shall be
expended
by the state by september 30th 2025.
section 2703 funding for mental health
and substance use disorder training for
health care professionals
paraprofessionals and public safety
officers
a in general in addition to amounts
otherwise available there is
appropriated to the secretary for fiscal
year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 80 million
dollars to remain available until
expended
for the purpose described in subsection
b b
use of funding the secretary acting
through the administrator of the health
resources and services administration
shall taking into consideration the
needs of rural and medically underserved
communities
use amounts appropriated by subsection a
to award grants or contracts to health
professions schools
academic health centers state or local
governments indian tribes and tribal
organizations
or other appropriate public or private
non-profit entities
or consortia of entities including
entities promoting multi-disciplinary
approaches to plan develop operate or
participate
in health professions and nursing
training activities for healthcare
students residents professionals
paraprofessionals trainees and public
safety officers
and employers of such individuals in
evidence informed strategies for
reducing and addressing suicide
burnouts mental health conditions and
substance use disorders among health
care professionals
section 2704 funding for education and
awareness campaign encouraging healthy
work conditions and use of mental health
and substance use disorder services by
healthcare professionals
a in general in addition to amounts
otherwise available there is
appropriated to the secretary for fiscal
year 2021 out of any money in the
treasury not otherwise appropriated
20 million dollars to remain available
until expended for the purpose described
in subsection b
b use of funds the secretary acting
through the director of the centers for
disease control and prevention and in
consultation with the medical
professional community
shall use the amounts appropriated by
subsection a to carry out a national
evidence-based education and awareness
campaign
directed at healthcare professionals and
first responders such as emergency
medical service providers
and employers of such professionals and
first responders
such awareness campaign shall one
encourage primary prevention of mental
health conditions
and substance use disorders and
secondary and tertiary prevention
by encouraging health care professionals
to seek support and treatment for their
own
mental health and substance use concerns
and to
help such professionals to identify risk
factors in themselves and others and
respond to such risks
section 2705 funding for grants for
health care
providers to promote mental health among
their health professional workforce
a in general in addition to amounts
otherwise available
there is appropriated to the secretary
for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 40 million
dollars to remain available until
expended for the purpose described in
subsection b
b use of funds the secretary acting
through the administrator of the health
resources and services administration
shall
taking into consideration the needs of
rural and medically underserved
communities
use amounts appropriated by subsection a
to award grants or contracts to entities
providing
health care including health care
providers associations
and federally qualified health centers
to establish enhance or expand
evidence-informed programs or protocols
to promote mental health among their
providers other personnel and members
section 2706 funding for community-based
funding
for local substance use disorder
services a in general
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
secretary for fiscal year 2021 out of
any money in the treasury not otherwise
appropriated
30 million dollars to remain available
until expended to carry out the purpose
described in subsection b
b use of funds one in general the
secretary acting through the assistant
secretary for mental health and
substance use
and in consultation with the director of
the centers for disease control and
prevention shall
award grants to support states local
tribal and territorial governments
tribal organizations nonprofit
community-based organizations
and primary and behavioral health
organizations to support community-based
overdose prevention programs
syringe services programs and other harm
reduction services
two use of grants grant funds awarded
under this section to eligible entities
shall be used for preventing and
controlling the spread of infectious
diseases
and the consequences of such diseases
for individuals with substance use
disorder
distributing opioid overdose reversal
medication
to individuals at risk of overdose
connecting individuals at risk for or
with a substance use
disorder to overdose education
counseling and health education and
encouraging such individuals to take
steps to reduce the negative personal
and public health impacts of substance
use or misuse
section 2707 funding for community-based
funding for local behavioral health
needs
a in general in addition to amounts
otherwise available there is
appropriated to the secretary for fiscal
year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 50 million
dollars
to remain available until expended to
carry out the purpose described in
subsection b
b use of funds one in general the
secretary acting through the assistant
secretary for mental health and
substance use
shall award grants to state local tribal
and territorial governments
tribal organizations non-profit
community-based entities
and primary care and behavioral health
organizations
to address increased community
behavioral health needs
worsened by the coven 19 public health
emergency
two use of grants grant funds awarded
under this section to eligible entities
shall be used for promoting care
coordination among local entities
training the mental and behavioral
health workforce relevant stakeholders
and community
members expanding evidence-based
integrated models of care
addressing surge capacity for mental and
behavioral health needs
providing mental and behavioral health
services to individuals with mental
health needs
including co-occurring substance use
disorders as delivered by behavioral and
mental health professionals
utilizing telehealth services and
supporting enhancing or expanding mental
and behavioral health preventive and
crisis intervention services
section 2708 funding for the national
child traumatic stress network
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
secretary for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 10 million
dollars to remain available until
expended
for carrying out section 582 of the
public health service act
42 usc 290 hh1
with respect to addressing the problem
of high risk or medically underserved
persons who experience
violence-related stress section 2709
funding for project aware in addition to
amounts otherwise available there is
appropriated to the secretary for fiscal
year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
30 million dollars to remain available
until expended for carrying out section
520a
of the public health service act 42 usc
290 bb 32 with respect to advancing
wellness and resiliency in education
section 2710 funding for youth suicide
prevention
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
secretary for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 20 million
dollars
to remain available until expended for
carrying out sections 520e
and 520 e2 of the public health service
act
42 usc 290 bb 36
290 bb 36b section 2711
funding for behavioral health workforce
education and training
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
secretary for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
100 million dollars to remain available
until expended
for carrying out section 756 of the
public health service act
42 usc 294 e1
section 2712 funding for pediatric
mental health care access
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
secretary for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 80 million
dollars
to remain available until expended for
carrying out section 330m
of the public health service act 42 usc
254
c19 section 2713 funding for expansion
grants for certified community
behavioral health clinics
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
secretary acting through the assistant
secretary for mental health and
substance use
for fiscal year 2021 out of any money in
the treasury not otherwise appropriated
420 million dollars to remain available
until expended
for grants to communities and community
organizations that meet the criteria for
certified community behavioral health
clinics
pursuant to section 223a of the
protecting access to medicare act of
2014
42 usc 1396a note
subtitle 1 exchange grant program
section 2801
establishing a grant program for
exchange modernization
a in general out of funds appropriated
under subsection b
the secretary of health and human
services in the subtitle referred to as
the secretary
shall award grants to each american
health benefits exchange
established under section 1311b of the
patient protection and affordable care
act
42 usc 18031b
other than an exchange established by
the secretary under section 1321c
of such act 42 usc 18041c
that submits to the secretary an
application at such time and in such
manner and containing such information
as specified by the secretary for
purposes of enabling such exchange
to modernize or update any system
program or technology utilized by such
exchange
to ensure such exchange is compliant
with all applicable requirements
b funding in addition to amounts
otherwise available there is
appropriated for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 20 million
dollars to remain available until
september 30
2022 for carrying out this section
subtitle j continued assistance to real
workers
section 2901 additional enhanced
benefits under the railroad unemployment
insurance act
a in general section 2a5a of the
railroad unemployment insurance act 45
usc
352 a5a is amended one in the first
sentence a by striking march 14
2021 and inserting august 29 2021
b by striking or july 1 2020 and
inserting july 1 2020 or july 1 2021
and 2 by adding at the end the following
for registration periods beginning after
march 14th 2021 but on or before august
29
2021 the recovery benefit payable under
the subparagraph
shall be in the amount of eight hundred
dollars b clarification on authority to
use funds
funds appropriated under subparagraph b
of section 285 of the railroad
unemployment insurance act
45 usc 352 a5 shall be available to
cover the cost of recovery benefits
provided under such section 2a5 by
reason of the amendments
made by subsection a as well as to cover
the cost
of such benefits provided under section
2a5 as in effect on the day before the
date of
this enactment of this act 2902
extended unemployment benefits under the
railroad unemployment insurance act
a in general section 2c 2d of the
railroad unemployment insurance act 45
usc
352c 2d is amended 1 in clause 1
a and subclause 1 by striking 185 days
and inserting 305 days
b and sub clause 2 by striking 19
consecutive 14 day periods and inserting
31 consecutive 14 day periods
and two by striking six consecutive 14
day periods and inserting 18 consecutive
14 14-day periods two in class two
a by striking 120 days of unemployment
and inserting
240 days of unemployment b by striking
12 consecutive 14 day periods and
inserting 24 consecutive 14 day periods
and c by striking six consecutive 14-day
periods and inserting 18 consecutive
14-day periods
and 3 and clause 3 a by striking june 30
2021 and inserting june 30 2022
and b by striking the provisions of
clauses 1 and 2
shall not apply to any employee whose
extended benefit period under
sub-paragraph b begins after march 14th
2021 and shall not apply to any employee
with respect to any registration period
beginning after april 5th 2021 and
inserting the provisions of clauses 1
and 2
shall not apply to any employee with
respect to any registration period
beginning after august 29 2021
the clarification on authority to use
funds funds appropriated under either
the first or second sentence of clause 5
of section 2 c 2 d of the railroad
unemployment insurance act
shall be available to cover the cost of
additional extended unemployment
benefits
provided under such section 2c 2d by
reason of the amendments made by
subsection a
as well as to cover the cost of such
benefits provided under section
2c 2d as an effect on the day before the
date of enactment of this
act section 2903
extension of waiver of the seven day
waiting period for benefits under the
railroad unemployment insurance act
a in general section 2112 a
of the cares act 15 usc 9030a is amended
by striking march 14
2021 and inserting august 29 2021
b clarification on authority to use
funds funds appropriated under section
21
12 c of the cares act 15 usc 9030c
shall be available to cover the cost of
additional benefits payable due to
section 2112a
of such act by reason of the amendments
made by subsection a
as well as to cover the cost of such
benefits payable due to section
2112a as an effect on the day before the
date of enactment of this act
section 2904 railroad retirement board
and office of the inspector general
funding
in addition to amounts otherwise made
available there are appropriated for
fiscal year 2021 out of any money in the
treasury not otherwise appropriated
27 million 975 thousand dollars
to remain available until expended for
the railroad retirement board
to prevent prepare for and respond to
coronavirus
of which a six million eight hundred
thousand dollars shall be available
for additional hiring and overtime
bonuses as needed to administer the
railroad unemployment insurance act
and b 21 175 000
shall be to supplement not supplant
existing resources devoted to operations
and improvements
for the information technology
investment initiatives
of the railroad retirement board and two
five hundred thousand dollars to remain
available
until expended for the railroad
retirement board office of inspector
general
for audit investig investigatory and
review activities
subtitle k rate payer protection
section 2911 funding for ly heap in
addition to amounts otherwise available
there is appropriated for fiscal year
2021
out of any amounts in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
4 billion 500 million dollars to remain
available through september 30 2022
for additional funding to provide
payments under section 2602 b
of the low income home energy assistance
act of 1981
42 usc 8621 b
except that 2 billion 250 million
dollars of such amounts shall be
allocated
as though the total appropriation for
such payments for fiscal year 2021
was less than 1 billion 975 million
dollars and two
section 2607 b2b of such act
42 usc 8626 b2b
shall not apply to funds appropriated
under this section for fiscal year 2021.
section 2912 funding for water
assistance program
a in general in addition to amounts
otherwise available there is
appropriated to the secretary of health
and human services in this section
referred to as the secretary
for fiscal year 2021 out of any amounts
in the treasury not otherwise
appropriated
500 million dollars to remain available
until expended
for grants to states and indian tribes
to assist low-income households
particularly those with lowest incomes
that pay a high proportion of household
income for drinking water and wastewater
services
by providing funds to owners or
operators of public water systems or
treatment works to reduce
areas of and rates charged to such
households for such services
b allotment the secretary shall won a
lot amounts appropriated in this section
to a state or indian tribe
based on a the percentage of households
in the state
or under the jurisdiction of the indian
tribe with income equal or less than 150
percent
of the federal poverty line and be the
percentage of households in the state or
under the jurisdiction of the indian
tribe that spend more than 30 percent of
monthly income on housing
and two reserve up to three percent of
the amount appropriated in this section
for indian tribes and tribal
organizations subtitle l
assistance for older americans grand
families and kinship families
section 2921 supporting older americans
and their families
a appropriation in addition to amounts
otherwise available
there is appropriated for fiscal year
2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
one billion four hundred thirty four
million dollars to remain available
until expended
to carry out the older americans act of
1965
the allocation of amounts amounts made
available by subsection a shall be
available as follows
one 750 million dollars shall be
available to carry out part c of title
three of such act
to 25 million dollars shall be available
to carry out
title vi of such act including part c of
such title
three 460 million dollars shall be
available to carry out part b
of title iii of such act including 4a
supportive services of the types made
available for fiscal year 2020
b efforts related to coven 19
vaccination outreach
including education communication
transportation and other activities to
facilitate
vaccination of older individuals and c
prevention and mitigation activities
related to kova 19 focused on addressing
extended social isolation among
older individuals including activities
for investments
in technological equipment and solutions
or other strategies
aimed at alleviating negative health
effects of social isolation
due to long-term stay-at-home
recommendations for older
individuals for the duration of the
coven 19 public health emergency
for 44 million dollars shall be
available
to carry out part d of title three of
such act
five 145 million dollars shall be
available to carry out part e of title
three of such act
six ten million dollars shall be
available to carry out the long-term
care ombudsman
program under title vii of such act
section 2922 national technical
assistance center on grand families and
kinship families
a in general in addition to amounts
otherwise available
there is appropriated to the secretary
of health and human services for fiscal
year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
10 million dollars to remain available
through september 30th 2025
for the secretary acting through the
administrator of the administration for
community living
to establish directly or through grants
or contracts
a national technical assistance center
on grand families and kinship families
in this section referred to as the
center to provide training technical
assistance and resources
for government programs non-profit and
other community-based organizations and
indian tribes
tribal organizations and urban indian
organizations
that serve grand families and kinship
families to support the health and
well-being of members of grand families
and kinship families
including caregivers children and their
parents
the center shall focus primarily on
serving grand families and kinship
families in which the primary caregiver
is an adult age
55 or older or the child has one or more
disabilities
the activities of the center the center
shall one
engage experts to stimulate the
development of new and identify existing
evidence-based evidence informed
and exemplary practices or programs
related to health promotion
including mental health and substance
use disorder treatment
education nutrition housing financial
needs legal issues disability
self-determination caregiver support and
other issues
to help serve caregivers children and
their parents and grand families and
kinship families
to encourage and support the
implementation of the evidence-based
evidence-informed
and exemplary practices or programs
identified under paragraph one to
support grand families and kinship
families and to promote coordination of
services for grand families and kinship
families across systems that support
them
three facilitate learning across states
territories indian tribes tribal
organizations and urban indian
organizations
for providing technical assistance
resources and training related to issues
described in paragraph one to
individuals and entities across systems
that directly work with fran families
and kinship families four
health government programs non-profit
and other community-based organizations
and indian tribes
tribal organizations and urban indian
organizations
serving grand families and kinship
families to plan and coordinate
responses to assist grand families and
kinship families during national
state tribal territorial and local
emergencies and disasters
and five assist government programs in
nonprofit and other community based
organizations in promoting equity and
implementing culturally and
linguistically appropriate approaches
as the programs and organizations serve
grand families and kinship families
title iii committee on banking housing
and urban affairs
subtitle a defense production act of
1950
section 3101 coven 19 emergency medical
supplies
enhancement a supporting enhanced use of
the defense production act of 1950
in addition to funds otherwise available
there is appropriated for fiscal year
2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
10 billion dollars notwithstanding
section 304
e of the defense production act of 1950
50 usc
4534e to remain available until
september 30 2025.
to carry out titles one three seven and
such act in accordance with subsection b
b medical supplies and equipment one
testing ppe vaccines and other materials
except it
is provided in paragraph two amounts
appropriated in subsection a shall be
used for the purchase
production including the construction
repair and retrofitting of government
owned or private facilities as necessary
or distribution of medical supplies and
equipment including durable medical
equipment relating
to combating the copen 19 pandemic
including a in vitro diagnostic products
for the detection of sars co2
or the diagnosis of the virus that
causes covid19 and the
reagents and other materials necessary
for producing conducting and
administering such products in the
machinery equipment laboratory capacity
or other technology necessary to produce
such products face masks
b face masks and personal protective
equipment including face shields nitrile
gloves and
95 filtering face piece respirators and
any other masks or equipment including
durable medical equipment needed to
respond to the kobe 19 pandemic and the
materials machinery additional
manufacturing lines or facilities or
other technological technology necessary
to produce such equipment and see
drugs devices and biological products
that are approved cleared licensed or
authorized for use
in treating or preventing covid 19 and
symptoms related to cobit 19 and any
materials manufacturing machinery
additional
manufacturing or fill finish lines or
facilities
technology or equipment necessary to
produce or use such
drugs biological products or devices
including syringes vials
or other supplies or equipment related
to delivery distribution or
administration
two responding to public health
emergencies after september 30 2022
amounts appropriated in subsection a may
be used for any activity authorized by
paragraph one or
any other activity necessary to meet
critical public health needs of the
united states with respect to any
pathogen that the president has
determined has the potential for
creating a public health emergency
subtitle b housing provisions section
3201 emergency rental assistance a
funding
one appropriation in addition to amounts
otherwise available there is appropriate
to the secretary of the treasury for
fiscal year 2021 out of any
money in the treasury not otherwise
appropriated 21
million trillion 21 billion 550
million dollars to remain available
until september 30 2027 for making
payments to eligible guarantees under
this section
2 reservation of funds of the amount
appropriated under
paragraph 1 the secretary shall reserve
a 305 million dollars for making
payments under this section to the
commonwealth of puerto rico the united
states virgin islands guam
commonwealth of the northern mariana
islands since america samoa
the 30 million dollars for cost of the
secretary for the administration of
emergency rental assistance programs and
technical
assistance to recipients of any grants
made by the secretary to provide
financial and other assistance to
renters
see three million dollars for
administrative expenses of the inspector
general
relating to oversight of funds provided
in this section indeed two billion five
hundred million dollars for payments to
high
need grantees as provided in this
section b allocation of funds to
eligible grantees one
allocation for states and units of local
government a
in general the amount appropriated under
paragraph one of subsection a that
remains under the application of
paragraph two of such
subsection shall be allocated to
eligible grantees described in
subparagraphs a and b
of subsection f1 in the same manner as
the amount appropriated under section
501 of subtitle a of title
five of division in at the consolidated
appropriations act
2021 public law 116-260 is allocated to
states and units of local government
under subsection b
one of such section except that section
501b of such subtitle a
shall be applied one without regard to
one of paragraph one a
two by deeming the amount appropriated
under paragraph one of subsection a of
this act that remains
after the application of paragraph two
of such subsection to be
the amount deemed to apply for purposes
of applying clause 2 of sub
section 501 b1a of such subtitle a
3 by substituting 152 million dollars
for 200 million dollars
each place such term appears four in the
sub clause one of such
sub section 501 b1av by
substituting under section 3201 of the
american rescue plan act
of 2021 for under section 501 of the
subtitle
a of title 5 of division n of
consolidated appropriations act 2021
and 5 in subclass 2 of such
section 501 b1a5 by substituting
local government elects to receive funds
from the secretary under section 3201 of
the american rescue plan act of 2021
and will use the funds in a manner
consistent with such section for local
government
alex to receive funds from the secretary
under section 501 of subtitle a of title
5 of division n of the consolidated
appropriations act 2021
and we'll use the funds in a manner
consistent with such section
b pro rata adjustment the secretary
shall make adjustments in the amount of
the allocations determined under
sub-paragraph a of this paragraph
for entities described in such
subparagraph as necessary to ensure the
total amount of allocations made
pursuant
to such subparagraph does not exceed the
remainder appropriated amount
described in such sub paragraph two
allocations for territories
the amount reserved for under sec
subsection a2a
shall be allocated to eligible grantees
guaranteed in subsection f1c in the same
manner
as the amount appropriated under section
501 a2a of subtitle a of title 5 of
division n
of the consolidated appropriations act
2021 public law 116-260
is allocated under section 501 b3 of
such subtitle a to
eligible grantees described under
subparagraph c of such
section 501 b3 except that section 501
b3 of such
subtitle a shall be applied a and
paragraph a by inserting
of section 3201 of the american rescue
plan act of 2021
after the amount reserved under
subsection a2a
and b and clause 1 of paragraph b by
substituting the amount equal to
0.3 percent of the amount appropriated
under subsection a1 with the amount
equal to 0.3 percent of the amount
appropriated under subsection a1 of
section 3201
of american rescue plan of 2021. three
high need grantees the secretary should
allocate funds reserved under subsection
a2b to eligible grantees with a high
need for assistance under the section
with the number of very low income
renter households paying more than 50
percent of income on rent or living
in substandard or overcrowded conditions
rental market costs and change in
employment since february 2020
uses the factors for allocating funds
see payment schedule one in general
the secretary shall pay eligible
grantees not less than 40 percent of
each
eligible grantees total allocation
provided under subsection b within 60
days of enactment of this act
two subsequent payments the secretary
shall pay to eligible grantees
additional amounts and
tranches up to the full amount of each
such eligible grantees total allocation
in accordance with the
procedure established by the secretary
provided that any such procedure
established by the secretary shall
require
that an eligible eligible grantee must
have obligated not less than 75
of the funds already dispersed by the
secretary pursuant to this section prior
to disbursement of additional funds
d use of funds juan in general an
eligible grantee shall
only use the funds provided from
payments made under this section as
follows a financial assistance one in
general subject to clause 2 of the
subparagraph funds received by
an eligible grantee from payments made
under the section shall be used to
provide financial assistance to eligible
households
not to exceed 18 months including the
payment of
one rent two rent a rental arrears three
utilities and home energy
costs for utilities and home energy cost
arrears and five other expenses related
to housing as defined by the secretary
two limitations the aggregate amount of
financial assistance that
an eligible household may receive under
this section when combined with
financial assistance provided under
section 501 of subtitle a of title 5 of
division n of the consolidated
appropriations act
2021 public law 116-260 shall not
exceed 18 months b housing stability
services
not more than 10 percent of funds
received by an eligible grantee from
payments under this section may be used
to provide case management and other
services intended to help keep
households
stably housed see administrative costs
not more than fifteen percent of the
total amount paid
to an eligible grantee under the section
may be used for administrative costs
attributable
to providing financial assistance
housing stability services and other
affordable rental housing and eviction
prevention activities
including for data collection and
reporting requirements related to such
funds
d other affordable rental housing and
eviction prevention activities an
eligible grantee may use any funds from
payments under this section
that are unobligated on october 1 2022
for purposes in addition to these
those specified in this paragraph
provided that one such other purposes
are affordable rental
housing and eviction prevention purposes
as defined by the secretary serving very
low income families as such term is
defined in section 3b of the united
states housing act
of 1937 42 usc 1437 a b
and two prior to obligating any funds
for such purposes
the eligible grantee has obligated not
less than 75 percent of the total funds
allocated such
eligible grantee in accordance with this
section
two distribution of assistance amounts
provide appropriated under subsection a
one of the sections shall be subject to
the same terms and conditions that apply
under paragraph four of section 501 c of
subtitle a of title five of division n
of the consolidated appropriations act
2021 public law 116-260
two amounts appropriated under
subsection a1 of section 501 e
reallocation of funds one in general
beginning march 31 2022 the secretary
shall
reallocate funds out located to eligible
grantees in accordance with subsection b
but not yet paid in accordance with
subsection c2
according to a procedure established by
the secretary to eligibility for
reallocated funds
the secretary shall require an eligible
grantee to have obligated 50
of the total amount of funds allocated
to such eligible grantee under
subsection b to be
eligible to receive funds reallocated
under paragraph one of this subsection
three payment of reallocated funds by
the secretary the secretary shall pay to
each
eligible grantee eligible for a payment
of reallocated funds
described in paragraph two of the
subsection the amount allocated to such
eligible
grantee in accordance with the procedure
established by the secretary in
accordance with paragraph one of this
subsection
for use of reallocated funds eligible
grantees may use any funds
received in accordance with this
subsection only for purposes specified
in
paragraph one of subsection d f
definitions in this section
one eligible grantee the term eligible
grantee means any of the following a the
fifty states of the united states of
and the district of columbia b a unit of
local government is defined in paragraph
five c
the commonwealth of puerto rico the
united states virgin islands guam
the commonwealth of the northern mariana
islands and america samoa
two eligible household the term eligible
household means
a total of one or more individuals who
are obligated to pay rent on a
residential dwelling and with respect to
which the
eligible grantee involved determines
that a
one or more individuals within the
household has one qualified for
unemployment benefits or two
experienced a reduction in household
income incurred significant costs or
experience other financial hardship
during or do
directly or indirectly to the
coronavirus pandemic be
one or more individuals within the
household can demonstrate a risk
of experiencing homelessness or housing
instability and see the household as a
low-income family
as such term is defined in section 3b of
the united states housing act of 1937 42
usc
1437 a b three inspector general the
term inspector general means the
inspector general or the department of
the treasury for secretary the term
secretary means the secretary of the
treasury
five unit of local government the term
urine of local government has the
meaning given such determined section
501 is subtitle a of title v
of division n of the consolidated
appropriations act 2021 public law
116-260
g availability funds provided to be to
an eligible grantee under repayment
meant under this section shall remain
available through september 30 2025. h
extension of availability and a program
for existing funding paragraph 1 of
section 501e of subtitle a of title 5 of
division n
at the consolidated appropriations act
2021 public law 116-260
is a minute by striking december 31 2021
and inserting september 30 2022.
section 3202 emergency housing vouchers
a appropriation
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there was an appropriated to
the secretary of housing and urban
development and this section referred to
as the secretary
for fiscal year 2021 out of any money in
the treasury not otherwise appropriated
five billion dollars to remain available
until september 30 2030
for one incremental emergency vouchers
under subsection b
two renewals all the vouchers under
subsection b three fees for the
cost of administrating vouchers under
subsection b and other
eligible expenses defined by notice to
prevent prepare and respond to
corenovirus
to facilitate the leasing of the
emergency vouchers such as security
deposit assistance
and other costs related to retention and
support of participating owners and four
adjustments in the calendar year 2021
section 8 renewal
funding allocation including mainstream
vouchers for public housing
agencies that experience a significant
increase in voucher per unit cost due to
extraordinary circumstances or that
despite taking reasonable cost-saving
measures would otherwise be required to
terminate rental assistance for families
as a result of insufficient funding be
emergency vouchers one
in general the secretary shall provide
emergency rental assistance vouchers
under subsection a which shall be
tenant-based rental assistance under
section
8-0 of the united states housing act of
1937 42 usc 1437 fo
two qualifying individuals or families
to find for the purposes of this section
qualifying individuals or families or
those who are a homeless as such
term is defined in section 103 a of the
mckinney bento homeless assistance act
for
d2 usc 11302a be
at risk of homelessness as such term is
defined in section 401
1 of the mckinney-vento homeless
assistance act 42 usc 113601
c fleeing or attempting to flee domestic
violence dating violence
sexual assault stalking or human
trafficking as defined by the secretary
or d
recently homeless is determined by the
secretary and for whom providing rental
assistance will provide the families
homelessness or
having high risk of housing instability
three allocation the secretary shall
notify public housing agencies
of the number of emergency vouchers
provided under this section
to be allocated to the agency not later
than 60 days after the date of the
enactment of this act in accordance
with the formula that includes public
housing agency capacity ensures
geographic diversity including with
respect to rural areas among public
housing agencies administering the
housing choice voucher program for terms
and conditions a elections to administer
the secretary shall establish a
procedure for public housing agencies to
accept or decline the emergency vouchers
allocated to the agency in accordance
with the formula under some paragraph
three b failure to use
according to the formula under paragraph
three five waivers and alternative
requirements the secretary may waive or
specify alternative requirements for any
provision of the united states housing
act of 1937
42 usc 1437 or regulation applicable to
such statute other than requirements
related to fair housing
non-discrimination labor standards
and the environment upon a finding that
the waiver alternative requirement is
necessary to expedite or facilitate the
use of amounts made available in this
section
termination of sexuality is upon
tournament turnover after september 30
2023 a public housing agency may not
reissue any vouchers made available
under this section when assistance for
the family
assisted ends c technical assistance and
other costs
the secretary may use not more than 20
million dollars of the amounts made
available under this section for the
cost of the secretary of administering
and overseeing the implementation of
this section of the housing choice
voucher program generally
including information technology
financial reporting and other costs
of the amount set aside under this
section subsection the secretary may use
not more than 10 million dollars without
competition to make new awards or
increase prior
awards to existing technical assistance
providers to provide
an immediate increase in capacity
building and technical assistance to
public housing agencies
de-implementation
the secretary may implement the
provisions of this section by
notice section 2 3203
emergency assistance for rural housing
in addition to amounts otherwise
available
here is appropriated to the secretary of
agriculture for fiscal year 2021 out of
any money in the treasury not otherwise
appropriated
100 million dollars to remain available
until september 30 2022 to provide
grants under section 52182 of the
housing act
of 1949 or agreements entered into in
lieu of debt forgiveness or payments for
eligible households as authorized by
section 502 c5d
of the housing act of 1949 for temporary
adjustment of income losses for
residents of housing
financed or assisted under section five
one four five one five or five one six
of the housing act of 1949 who have
experienced income loss but are not
currently receiving federal rental
assistance
section 3204 housing counseling a
appropriation in addition to amounts
otherwise
available there was appropriated to the
neighborhood reinvestment corporation in
this section referred to as the
corporation for fiscal year 2021.
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 100 million
dollars to remain available until
september 30 2025 for grants to housing
counseling intermediaries
approved by the department of housing
and urban development state housing
finance agencies and neighborhood
neighbor works organizations for
providing housing counseling services
as authorized in the neighborhood
reinvestment corporation act 42 usc 8101
through 8107 and consistent with the
discretion set forth in section
606 a5 of such act 42 usc
8105a5 to design and administer grant
programs of the grant funds made
available under the subsection that less
than 40 percent salt
be provided to counseling organizations
that one target housing counseling
services to minority and low income
populations facing housing instability
or two
providing housing counseling services in
neighborhoods having high concentrations
of minority and low income populations
b limitation an aggregate amount
provided to neighbor works
organizations under this section shall
not exceed 15 of the total of grant
funds made available by subsection a
c administration and oversight the
corporation may retain a portion of the
amounts provided under this section
in a report in a proportion consistent
with its standard rate for program
administration
in order to cover its expenses related
to program administration oversight d
housing counseling services defined for
the purposes of this section the term
housing counseling services means
one housing counseling provided directly
to households facing housing instability
such as eviction default foreclosure
loss of income or homelessness two
education outreach training technology
upgrades and other program related
support and three operational oversight
funding for grantees and subgrantees
that receive funds under the subs
under the section section 3205
homelessness assistance and supportive
services program a appropriation in
addition to amounts otherwise available
there is appropriated to the secretary
of housing and urban development in this
section referred to as the secretary
for fiscal year 2021 out of any money in
the treasury not otherwise appropriated
five billion dollars to remain available
until september 30 2025
except that amounts authorized under
subsection d3 shall remain
available until september 30 2029 for
assistance under title ii of the
cranston gonzalez
national affordable housing act 42 usc
two one for the following activities to
primarily benefit qualifying individuals
or families one tenant-based
rental assistance two the development
and support of affordable
housing pursuant to section two and two
a of the cranston gonzalez
national affordable housing act 42 usc
12742a
the act herein three supportive services
to qualifying individuals or families
not already receiving such supportive
services
including a activities listed in section
40129
of the mckinney-vento homeless homeless
assistance act
42 usc 1136029 b
housing counseling and c homeless
prevention
services for the acquisition and
development of non-congregate shelter
units all
or a portion of which may be converted
to permanent affair
affordable housing b be used as
emergency shelter under subtitle b of
title iv the mckinney-vento assistance
homeless assistance act
42 usc 11371-311378
c be converted to permanent housing
under sub title c of title iv the mckent
event to homeless assistance act
42 usc 11381-11389 or d remain as a
non-congregate shelter units
b qualifying individuals or families
defined for the purpose of this section
qualifying individuals or families or
those who are one homeless as defined in
section
103a of the mckinney-vento homeless
assistance act 42 usc 11302
a two at risk of homelessness
as defined in section 401-1 of the
mckinney-vento homeless assistance act
42 usc 13601 three fleeing or attempting
to flee domestic violence dating
violence sexual assault stalking or
human trafficking is defined by the
secretary for
in other populations we're providing
supportive services or assistance under
section 2 and 2a
of the act 42 usc 12742a would prevent
the
family's homelessness or would serve
those with the greatest risk of housing
instability or two
veterans and families that include a
veteran family member that meet one of
the follow
one of the preceding criteria c terms
and conditions one
funding restrictions the cost limits in
section 212 e
42 usc 12742e the commitment
requirements
section 218g 42usc 12748g the matching
requirements in section 220
42 usc 12750 and the set-aside for
housing development
developed sponsored around by community
housing development organizations
required in section 231 of the act
42 usc 12771 shall not apply for amounts
made available in this section
two administrative costs notwithstanding
sections 212c
and d1 of the act 42 usc 12742
c and d1 are the funds made available in
this section for carrying out activities
authorized by this section a grantee may
use up to 15 percent of its allocation
for administrative and planning costs
three operating expenses notwithstanding
sections 212 212a and g of the act 42
usc 12742amg
a grantee may use up to additional five
percent of its allocation for the
payment of operating expenses
of community housing development
organizations and non-profit
organizations carrying out
activities authorized under this section
but only if a such funds are used to
develop the capacity of the community
housing development organization
or non-profit organization in the
jurisdiction or insular area to carry
out activities authorized around this
section and b
the community housing development
organization or nonprofit organization
complies with the limitation on
assistance in section 234b of the act
42 usc 12774b for contracting a grantee
when contracting with
service providers engaged directly in
the provision of services under
paragraph a3 shall to the extent
practicable enter into contracts and
amounts that cover the
actual total program cost and
administrative overhead to provide the
services contracted deallocation one
formula assistance
except as provided in paragraphs two and
three the secretary shall allocate
amounts made available under this
section pursuant to section 217 of the
act 42 usc
12747 to grantees that receive
allocations pursuant to that same
formula in fiscal year 2021
and shall make such allocations within
30 days of enactment of this act two
technical assistance up to 25 million
dollars of the
amounts made available under this
section shall be used without
competition to make new awards or
increasing prior awards to existing
technical assistance providers to
provide
an immediate increase in capacity
building and technical assistance
available to only any grantees
implementing activities or projects
consistent with this section other costs
up to 50 million dollars the amounts
made available
under this section shall be used for the
administrative costs to oversee and
administer implementation of the section
of the home program generally
including information technology
financial reporting and other costs four
waivers are alternative requirements the
secretary may waive or specify
alternative requirements for any
provision of the
cranston gonzales national affordable
housing act 42 usc
1270 and titles one and four of the
mckinney-vento homelessness act 42 usc
1301
1136 11360 or regulation
for the administration of the amounts
made available under this section other
than requirements related to fair
housing non-discrimination labor
standards in the environment upon
finding that the waiver
or alternative requirement is necessary
to expedite or facilitate the use of
amounts made available under this
section
section 3206 homework owner assistance
fund
a appropriation in addition to amounts
otherwise available there was
appropriated for the secretary of the
treasury for the homeowner assistance
fund established
under subsection c for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
9 billion 961 million dollars to remain
available until september 30 2025 for
qualified expenses that meet the
purposes specified under subsection c
and expenses described in subsection d1
b definitions in this section
one conforming loan limit the term
conforming loan limit means the
applicable limitation
governing the maximum original principal
obligation of a mortgage secured by a
single-family residence a mortgage
secured by two family residents
a mortgage secured by three family
residents or a mortgage secured by four
family rabbit
residents as determined and adjusted
annually under section 302 b2 of the
federal national mortgage association
charter act 12 usc 1717b2 and section
305 a2
at the federal homeland mortgage
corporation act 12 usc one four
five four a two two dwelling the term
dwelling means any building structure or
portion thereof which is occupied as or
designed or intended for occupancy as a
residence by one or more individuals
three eligible entity the term eligible
entity means a
estate or b any entity eligible for
payment under subsection f4
mortgage the term mortgage means any
credit transaction a that is secured by
a mortgage
deed of trust or other consensual
security interest on a principal
residence for borrower that is one
a one to four unit dwelling or two
residential real property that includes
a one to four unit dwelling and b
the unpaid principal balance of which
was at the time of origination not more
than the conforming loan limit
five fund the term fund means the
homeowner assistance fund established
intersection
subsection c six secretary the term
secretary means the secretary of
treasury
seven state the term state means any
state of the united states the district
of columbia the commonwealth of puerto
rico guam american samoa
the united states virgin islands at the
commonwealth of the northern mariana
islands sea establishment of fun one
establishment qualified expenses there
was established in the department of the
treasury
a homeowner assistance fund to mitigate
financial hardships
associated with the coronavirus pandemic
but providing such funds as are
appropriated by subsection a
to eligible entities for the purpose of
preventing homeowner mortgage
delinquencies
defaults foreclosures loss of utilities
or home energy services
and displacements of homeowners
experiencing financial hardship up to
january 21 2020
through qualified expenses related to
mortgages and housing which include a
mortgage payment assistance b
financial assistance to allow a
homeowner to reinstate
a mortgage or to pay other housing
related costs related to a period of
forbearance delinquency or default
c principal reduction d facilitating
interest rate reductions
e payment assistance for one utilities
including electric gas home energy and
water two internet service including
broadband internet
access service as defined in section 81b
of title 47 code of federal regulations
or any success or regulation
three homeowners list insurance flood
insurance and mortgage insurance and
four
homeowners association condominium
associate association fees or common
charges
f reimbursement of funds expended by a
state level government or
designated entity under subsection f
during the period beginning on january
21 2020 and ending on the date
that the first funds are dispersed by
the eligible entity under the homeowner
assistance fund for the purpose of
providing housing
or payment utility payment assistance to
homeowners or otherwise providing funds
to
prevent foreclosure or post-foreclosure
eviction of a homeowner or prevent
mortgage delinquency or loss of housing
or utilities as a response to the
coronavirus disease covid pandemic
ng any other assistance or to promote
housing stability for homeowners
including preventing mortgage
delinquency default foreclosure
post-foreclosure eviction of a homeowner
or the loss of utility or home energy
services as determined by the secretary
mister
two targeting not less than sixty
percent of amounts made to each eligible
entity allocated amounts under
subsection
d or f shall be used for qualified
expenses that assist homeowners having
incomes
equal to or less than 100 of the area
median income for their household size
or equal to or less than 100
of the median income for the united
states as determined by the secretary of
housing
and urban development whichever is
greater eligible entities shall
prioritize remaining funds to socially
disadvantaged individuals
d allocation of funds one administration
of any amounts made available under the
section the secretary shall reserve a
to the department of the treasury an
amount not to exceed 40 million dollars
to administer
and oversee the fund and to provide
technical assistance to eligible
entities for the creation and
implementation of state and tribal
programs to administer assistance from
the fund
and be the inspector general of the
department of the treasury an amount to
not to exceed
2.6 million dollars for oversight of the
program under the section
two four states after the application of
paragraphs one four and five of the
subsection and subject to paragraph
three of the subsection
the secretary shall allocate the
remaining funds available within the
homeowners assistance fund
to each state of the united states the
district of columbia and the
commonwealth of puerto rico
based on homeowner needs for such state
relative to all states of the united
states the district of columbia and the
commonwealth of puerto rico
as the date of the enactment of this act
which is determined by
reference to a the average number of
unemployed individuals measured over a
period of time not fewer than three
months and not more than 12 months and b
the total number of mortgages with
mortgage with one mortgage payment
center more than 30 days past two
or two mortgages in foreclosure three
stop small state minimum
a in general each state of the united
states the district of columbia and the
commonwealth of puerto rico shall
receive no less than 50 million dollars
for the purposes established in c
b prada adjustments the secretary shall
adjust on a pro-rata basis the amount of
permits for each state of the united
states the district of columbia
and the commonwealth of puerto rico
determined under the subsection without
regard to the subparagraph
to the extent necessary to comply with
the requirements of subsection
subparagraph a four territory set aside
notwithstanding any provision of the
subsection of the amounts appropriate
under subsection a the secretary
shall reserve 30 million dollars to be
dispersed to guam american samoa
the united states virgin islands and the
commonwealth of northern mariana islands
based on each
territory's share of the mine total
population of all such territories is
determined by the secretary
for the purposes of this paragraph
population shall be determined based on
the most recent year for which data
are available from the united states
census bureau five
tribal set aside the secretary shall
allocate funds to any eligible entity
designated under subsection f pursuant
to the requirements of that subsection
e distribution of funds to states one in
general the secretary shall make
payments beginning not lighter than 45
days after the enactment of this act
from amounts allocated under subsection
d
to eligible entities that have not
notified the secretary that have
notified the secretary that they request
to reque
receive payments from the fund and that
the eligible entity will use such
payments in compliance with this section
two reallocation if a state does not
request allocated funds by the 45th day
of the date of the enactment of this act
such state shall not be eligible for a
payment from the secretary pursuant to
the section
and the secretary shall by the 180th day
after the date of enactment of this act
we allocate any funds
who that were not requested by such
state among the states that have
requested funds by the 45th day
after the date of the enactment of this
act for any certain for any such
reallocation of funds the secretary
shall adhere to the requirements of
subsection d
except for paragraph one to the greatest
extent possible provided that the
secretary shall also take into
consideration
in determining such reallocation a
state's remaining need
and the state's record of using payments
from the fund to serve homeowners at
disproportionate rates of mortgage
default foreclosure displacement
including homeowners having incomes
equal to or greater than
than 100 of the area immediate income
for the household size or 100 of the
medium income for the united
for the united states as determined by
the secretary of housing and urban
development whichever is greater and
minority homeowners
f tribal set aside one set aside
notwithstanding any other provision of
the section of the amounts appropriated
under subsection a the secretary shall
use five percent to make payments
to entities that are eligible for
payments under clauses one and two of
section
501v2a of subtitle a of title v
a division n of the consolidated
appropriations act 2021 public law
116-260 for the purposes described in
subsection c
two allocation and payment the secretary
shall allocate the funds set aside under
paragraph one using the allocation
formulas described in clauses one and
two of section 501 b2a
of subparagraph subtitle a of title 5
of division n of the consolidated
appropriations act 2021 public law
116-260
and she'll make payments of such amounts
beginning no later than 45 days after
enactment of this act
to entities eligible for payments under
clauses 1 and 2 of section 501b2a
a subtitle of title 5 a division n of
the consolidated appropriations act
2021 public law 116-260 that notified
the secretary that they request to
receive payments allocated from the fund
by the secretary for purposes described
under subsection c
and will not use such payments in
compliance with this section three
adjustment allocations provided under
under the subsection may further
adjusted as provided by section 501 b2b
of subtitle a
of title 5 of division n of the
consolidated appropriations act
2021 public law 116-260
section 3207 relief measures for section
502 and 504
direct loan borrowers a appropriation in
addition to amounts otherwise available
there is appropriated to the secretary
of agriculture in the section referred
to as the secretary for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not was
not otherwise appropriate 39 million
dollars to remain available until
september 30th 2023 for direct loans
made under section 501
502 and 504 the housing act of 1949 42
usc
1472-1474 b administrative expenses
the secretary may not use more than
three percent of the amounts
appropriated under the section for
administrative purposes
section 3208 fair housing activities a
appropriation in addition to amounts
otherwise available there is
appropriated to the secretary of housing
and urban development
in the section referred to as secretary
for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 20 million
dollars to remain available until
september 30th 2023 for the fair housing
initiatives program
under section 561 of the housing and
community development act
of 1987 42 usc 361 6a
to ensure fair housing organizations
have additional resources to address
fair housing inquiries
complaints investigations education and
outreach activities and costs of
delivering or adapting services
during or relating to the coronavirus
pandemic the administrative
expenses the secretary may not use more
than three percent of the amounts
appropriate under this section for
administrative purposes
subtitle c small business ssbci section
3301
state small business credit initiative a
state small business credit
initiative one in general the state
small business credit initiative of 2010
12 usc 57 um at sec
is amended a in the section three zero
zero three
one in subsection b one by amending
paragraph one
to read as follows one in general not
later than 30 days after the date of
enactment of subsection d
the secretary shall allow federal funds
to participating states so that each
state is eligible to receive an
amount equal to what the state would
receive under the 2021 allocation
as determined under paragraph two two in
paragraph two
a by striking 2009 each place such term
appears ensuring 2021 b
by striking 2008 each place um
such term appears and inserting 2020 c
in sub-paragraph a
by striking the secretary and inserting
with respects to states other than
tribal governments
the secretary d in sub-paragraph c-1 by
striking 2007
and inserting 2019 and e by adding at
the
end of the following c separate
allocation for tribal governments
one in general with respect to states
that are tribal governments the
secretary shall determine the 2021
allocation by allocating
500 million dollars among the tribal
governments in the proportion the
secretary determines appropriate
including
with consideration to available
employment and economic data regarding
such
tribal government two notice of intent
timing of allocation with respect to
allocations to states that are tribal
governments
the secretary may one require tribal
governments that individually or jointly
wish to participate in the program to
file a notice of intent with the
secretary
not later than 30 days after the date of
enactment of subsection d
and two notwithstanding paragraph one
allocate federal funds to participating
tribal governments not later than 60
days after the date of enactment of
subsection d
d employment data if the secretary
determines that employment data with
respect to a state is unavailable from
the bureau of labor statistics of the
department of labor
the secretary shall consider such other
economic and employment data that is
otherwise available for purposes of
determining the employment data of such
state and
three by striking paragraph three and
two in subsection c
one in paragraph one a three by
inserting before the period the
following that have delivered loans or
investments to eligible businesses
and two by amending paragraph four to
read as follows
four termination of availability of
amounts not transferred
a in general any portion of a
participating state's
allocated amount that has not been
transferred to the state under the
section may be deemed by the secretary
to be no longer allocated to the state
and no longer available to the state
and shall be returned to the general
fund of the treasury or reallocated as
described as
a sub-paragraph be if one the second
one-third
of a state's allocated amount has not
been transferred to
the state before the end of the third of
the three-year period beginning on the
date that the secretary approves the
state for participation or two
the last third of the state's allocated
amount has not been transferred to the
state before the end of the end
of the six-year period beginning on the
date that the secretary approves the
state for participation
the reallocation any amount deemed by
the secretary to no longer be allocated
to a state and no longer
available to such state under
sub-paragraph a may be reallocated by
the secretary
to other participating states in making
such a reallocation the secretary shall
now take into account the minimum
allocation
requirements under subsection 2 b2b or
the specific allocation for tribal
governments described under subsection
b2c b in section 3004 d by striking date
of enactment of this act each place it
appears and inserting the date of the
enactment of section
303 d c in section
3005 b by striking date of enactment of
the state each place that appears in
inserting date of enactment
section 3003 d d in section
3006 b4 by striking date of enactment of
this act and inserting date of the
enactment of section 3003 d
e in section 3007b by striking march
31 2011 and it's entering march 31
2022 f in section 3009 by striking date
of enactment of this act each place that
appears inserting date of the enactment
of section 3003
d and g in section 3 0 1 1
b by striking data of the enactment of
this act each place it appears and
inserting date of the enactment of
section
3003 d 2 appropriation a
in general in addition to amounts
otherwise available there is hereby
appropriated to the secretary of the
treasury for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriate 10 billion dollars
to
remain available until expended to
provide support to small businesses
responding to and recovering from the
economic effects of the coven 19
pandemic
ensure businesses enterprise business
enterprises
owned and controlled by the socially
economic disadvantage of individuals
have access to credit and investments
provide technical assistance to help
small businesses applying for various
support programs and to pay reasonable
cost of
administering such initiative b recision
with respect to amounts appropriated
under
sub-paragraph a one the secretary of the
treasury shall complete all
disbursements and remaining obligations
before september 30th 2030
and 2 any amounts that remain unexpected
whether obligated or unobligated on
september 30th 2030 shall be rescinded
and deposited into the general fund of
the treasury
b additional allocations to support
businesses enterprises owned and
controlled by socially and economically
and disadvantaged individuals section
3003 of the state small business credit
initiative act of 2010
12 usc 5702 is amended by outing at the
following
at the end the following d additional
allocations to support businesses
business enterprises owned and
controlled by socially and anomaly
disadvantaged individuals
of the amounts appropriated for fiscal
year 2021
to carry out the program the secretary
secretary schall
won allocate one one billion five
hundred million
to states from from funds allocated
under the section
and by regulation or other guidance
prescribed program requirements
that the funds be expended for business
enterprises owned and controlled by
socially and economically disadvantaged
individuals and two allocate such
amounts to states based on the
needs of business enterprises owned and
controlled by socially
and economically disadvantaged
individuals as determined by the
secretary in each state and not subject
to the allocation formula described
under subsection b
e incentive allocations to support
business enterprises owned and
controlled by socially and economically
disadvantaged individuals
of the amounts appropriated for fiscal
year 2021 to carry out the program the
secretary
shall set aside one billion dollars for
an incentive program under which the
sucker
secretarial
secretary shall increase the second
third and last third allocations for
states that demonstrate robust support
as determined by the secretary for
business concerns owned and controlled
by socially and economically
disadvantaged individuals
in the deployment of prior allocation
amounts see
additional allocations to support very
small businesses
section 3003 of the small state business
credit initiative act of 2010
12 usc 5702 as amended by subsection b
is further amended by adding at the at
the end the following f
additional allocations to support very
small businesses one in general of the
amounts appropriated to carry out the
program the secretary shall allocate
not less than 500 million dollars to
states from funds allocated under the
subs
under the section to be expended for
very small businesses
two very small businesses defined in
this subsection the term very small
business
a means a business with fewer more than
fewer than 10 employees and b
may include independent contractors and
sole proprietors
d ctfi and mdi participation plan
section 3004 the state
small business credit initiative act of
2010 12 usc 5703 is amended by adding at
the end of
the following e cdfi and mdi
participation plan the secretary may not
prove a state to be a
participating state unless a state has
provided the secretary with a plan
detailing how more minority depository
institutions
and community development financial
institutions will be encouraged to
participate in state programs
e pandemic response plan section 3004 of
the
state small business credit initiative
act of 2010 12 usc 5703
as amended by subsection d is further
amended by adding at the
at the end the following f pandemic
response plan the secretary may not
approve a state to be a participating
state unless the
state has provided the secretary with a
description of how the state will be
expeditiously utilized funds to support
small businesses including
business enterprises owned and
controlled by socially and economically
disadvantaged individuals
and responding to and recovering from
the economic effects of the covenant 19
pandemic
f technical assistance section 3009 of
the state small business
credit initiative act of 2010 12 usc
5708 is amended by adding at the end the
following e
technical assistance of the amounts
appropriated for fiscal year 2021 to
carry out the program
500 million dollars may be used by the
secretary to one provide funds to the
states to carry out a technical
assistance plan
under which a state will provide legal
accounting and financial advisory
services either directly or contracted
with legal accounting and financial
advisory firms with priority given to
business
enterprises owned and controlled by
socially and economically disadvantaged
individuals
to very small businesses and businesses
enterprises owned and controlled by
socially and economically
disadvantaged individuals applying for a
state programs under the program
and b other state or federal programs
that support small businesses
two transfer amounts the minority
business development agencies are the
that the agency may use such amounts in
a manner the agency determines
appropriate
including through contracting with third
parties to provide technical assistance
to business enterprises owned and
controlled by socially and economically
disadvantaged individuals applying to a
state programs under the program and b
other state or federal programs at
support small business and three
contract with legal accounting and
financial advisory firms were priority
given to business enterprises owned and
controlled by socially and economically
disadvantaged individuals to provide
technical assistance to business
enterprises owned
and controlled by socially and
economically disadvantaged
individuals applying to a state programs
under the program and b
other state or federal programs that
support small businesses g
inclusion inclusion of tribal
governments section
300210 of the small state small business
credit initiative
act of 2010 12 usc 5701 10 is amended
one
and some paragraph c by striking and and
at the end two
and some paragraph d by striking the
period at the end and inserting
and and three by adding at the end of
the following
e a tribal government or a group of
tribal governments that jointly apply
for an allocation
h definitions section 3002 of the state
small business credit
initiative act of 2010 12 usc 5701
is amended by adding at the end the
following 15 business enterprise
owned and controlled by socially and
economically disadvantaged individuals
the term business enterprise owned and
controlled by socially and economically
disadvantaged individuals
means a business that a if privately
owned 51
is owned by one or more socially and
economically
disadvantaged individuals b if publicly
owned 51
of the stock is owned by one or more
socially and economically disadvantaged
individuals and three
and c in the case of a mutual
institution a majority of the board of
directors count holders in the community
which the institution services
is predominantly comprised of socially
and economically disadvantaged
individuals
16 community development financial
institution the term community
development financial institution
has the meaning given that the term
under section 103 of the rigel
community development and regulatory
improvement act of 1994
17 minority depository institution the
term minority depository institution has
the meaning given that the term under
section
308b of the financial institutions
reform recovery and enforcement act of
1989
18 socially and economically
disadvantaged individual the term
socially
economically disadvantaged individual
means an individual who is socially
disadvantaged
individual or an economically
disadvantaged individual as such terms
are divine
respectively under section 8 of the
small business act 15 usc 637 and the
regulations they're under
19 tribal government the term tribal
government means the recognized
governing body of any indian or alaska
native tribe
band nation pueblo village community or
component ban
or component reservation individually
identified including parenthetically to
the list
published most recently as the date of
the enactment of this paragraph pursuant
to section
104 the federally recognized indian
tribalist act of 1994
25 usc 5131 one rule of application the
amendments made by the section shall
apply with respect to funds appropriated
under this section and funds appropriate
on or after the date of enactment of the
section
subtitle d public transportation
section 3101 3401 federal transit
administration grants a federal transit
administration appropriation
one in general in addition to amounts
otherwise made available but
there are appropriate for fiscal year
2021 out of any funds in the treasury
not otherwise appropriate
30 billion 461 million 355
5534 to remain available until september
30th 2024 that shall a be good for
be for grants to eligible recipients
under section 50 5307
5309 5310 and 5311 of title 49
united states code to prevent prepare
for and respond to coronavirus and b
not be subject to any prior restriction
on the total amount of funds available
for implementation
or execution of programs authorized
under sections 5307 5310 or 5311 of such
title
two availability of funds for operating
expenses a in general notwithstanding
subsection a1 or b
a section 5307 in section 5310 b2a
of title 49 united states codes funds
provided under this section other than
subsection b4 shall be available for the
operating expenses
of transit agencies to prevent prepare
for and respond to the coronavirus
public health emergency
including beginning on january twenty
twenty twenty
one reimbursement for payroll public
transportation including payroll and
expenses of private
providers of public transportation two
operating costs to maintain service due
to lost revenue due to a result of the
coronavirus public health emergency
including the purchase of personal
protective equipment and three paying
the administrative leave of operations
or contractor personnel due to
reductions in service b
use of funds funds described in
sub-paragraph b
one available for media obligation not
withstanding requiring such expenses to
be included in a transportation
improvement program
long-range transportation plan state
transportation plan state white
statewide transportation improvement
program under sections 5303 and 5304 of
title 49 united states code
two directed to payroll in operations of
public transportation including payroll
and expenses of private providers of
public transportation
unless a recipient certifies an
administrator of the public transit
administration that the recipient has
not furloughed any employees
three use to provide a federal share of
the cost for any grant made under the
section of 100
b allocation of funds one urbanized area
formula grants a
in general of the amounts made available
under subsection a
26 billion 86 million hundred and
eighty thousand two hundred twenty seven
dollars shall be for grants to
recipients and sub recipients
under section 5307 of title 49 united
states code
and shall be administered as if such
funds were provided under section 5307
of such title
b allocation amounts made available
under sub-paragraph a shall be
appropriated to urbanized areas based on
data contained in the national transit
database such that
one each urbanized area shall receive an
import portion
of an amount that when combined with
amounts that were otherwise made
available to such urbanized area
for similar activities to prevent
prepare for and respond to chronovirus
is equal to 132 percent of the urbanized
areas 2018 operating costs and two
for funds remaining after the
apportionment date apportionment
described in clause 1 such as funds
shall be apportioned such that one each
urbanized area that did not receive an
apportionment under clause 1 shall
receive an enforcement equal to
25 percent of the urbanized areas 2018
operating costs and two
each urbanized areas other underclaws
won
when the amounts that were otherwise
made available prior to clause 1
in that urbanized area for similar
activities prevent prepare for and
respond to coronavirus
are equal to or greater than 130 percent
of the urbanized areas 2018
operating costs but do not exceed 132
of such costs such urbanized areas shall
receive an apportionment equal to 10 of
the urban areas
2018 operating costs in addition to
amounts apportioned to the urbanized
area under their claws
two formula grants for the enhanced
mobility of seniors and individuals with
disabilities a in general
of the amounts made available under
subsection a 50 million dollars shall be
for grants
to recipients or sub-recipients eligible
under section 5310 of title 49 united
states could and shall be apportioned to
in accordance with such section b
allocation
ratio amounts made available under
sub-paragraph a shall be allocated the
same ratio
as funds were provided under section
5310 of title 49 united states code for
fiscal year 2023
formula grants for rural areas and a in
general and the amounts made available
under subsection a
317 billion
million 214 000 and 13 shall be for
grants to recipients or sub-recipients
eligible under section
5311 of title 49 united states code and
shall be
administered as if the funds were
provided under section 5311 of such
title and shall be apportioned
in accordance with such section except
as described in paragraph b
b allocation ratio amounts made
available under cell paragraph a to
states as defined in section 5302 of
title 49 united states code
shall be allocated to such states based
on data contained in the national trust
database such
that
one any state that received an amount
for similar activities to prevent
prepare for and respond to coronavirus
that is equal to or greater than 150
percent of the combined
2018 rural operating costs of the
recipients and sub-recipients in such
states shall receive an amount equal to
5
of such stage 2018 rule operating costs
to any state that does not receive an
allocation
under clause 1
that received an amount for similar
activities to prevent prepare for and
respond to coronavirus that is equal to
or greater than 140 percent of the
combined 2018 rural operating costs
of the recipients and sub-recipients in
that state shall receive an amount
equal to 10 of such state's 2018 rural
operating costs and three
any state that does not receive an
allocation under clauses one or two
shall receive an amount equal to 20
percent
of such states 2018 rule operating costs
for capital investments in general the
amount
on subsection a 1 1
425 million dollars shall be grants
administered under subsections d
and e of section 5309 of title 49 united
states code
and two 250 million dollars shall be for
grants administered under subsection h
of section 53 of 9. title 49 united
states code b funding distribution one
in general of the amounts made available
in subparagraph ai
1 billion 250 million shall be provided
to each recipient for all projects with
existing full funding grant agreements
that received allocations for fiscal
year 2019 or 2020 except that recipients
with projects
open for revenue service service are not
eligible to receive a grant under this
subparagraph
fund shall be provided proportionally
based on the non-capital investment
grant share of the amount
allocated to allocation of the amounts
made available in subparagraph
a one 175 million dollars shall be
provided to each
recipient for all projects with existing
full funding grant agreements that
received an allocation only prior to
official year 2019
except that projects open for revenue
service are not eligible to receive a
grant under this sub-paragraph
and no project may receive more than 40
of the amounts provided under this
clause
the administrator of the federal transit
administration shall proportionately
distribute
funds in excess of such percent and to
recipients for which the percent
of funds does not exceed 40 percent
one shall be provided proportionally
based on the non-capital investment
grant share of the amount allocated
three eligible recipients for amounts
made available in subparagraph
a to eligible recipient shall be any
recipient of an allocation under
subsection 8
of section 5309 of title 49 united
states code
or an applicant in the project
development phase described in paragraph
two of such
subsection four amount amounts
distributed under clauses one two and
three of subparagraph
a shall be provided notwithstanding the
limitation of any calculation
of the maximum amount of federal
financial assistance for the project
under subsection k2 c2 or h7 of section
5309 of title 49 united states code
section 5311 f services
a in general of the amounts made
available under subsection a in addition
to the amounts made available under
paragraph
three 100 million dollars shall be
available for grants to recipients
for bus operators that partner with
recipients or
sub-recipients of funds under section
5311 f
of title 49 united states code b
allocation ratio notwithstanding
paragraph 3 the administrator of the
federal transit administration
shall allocate amounts under
sub-paragraph a in the same ratio
as funds were provided under section
5311 of title 49 united states code
for fiscal year 2020 see exception
if a state or territory does not have
bus providers eligible under section
5311 f of title 49 united states code
funds under this paragraph may be used
by such state or territory for any
expense
eligible under section 5311 of title 49
united states code six planning a in
general
of the amounts made available under
subsection a 25 million dollars shall be
for grants to recipients eligible under
section 5307 of title 49 united states
code
for the planning of public
transportation associated with the
restoration of services as the
coronavirus public health emergency
concludes
and shall be available in accordance
with such section
b availability of funds for route
planning amounts made available under
subparagraph a shall be available for
route planning designed to
one increase ridership and reduce travel
times
while maintaining or expanding the total
level of vehicle revenue miles of
service provided in the planning period
or two make service adjustments to
increase the quality of frequency of
service provided to low-income riders
and disadvantaged neighborhoods or
communities c
limitation amounts made available under
sub-paragraph a shall not be used for
route planning related to transitioning
public
transportation service provided as of
the date of receipt of funds to a
transportation network company
or other third-party contract provider
unless the existing provider of public
transportation service is a third-party
contract provider
seven recipients and sub-recipients
requiring additional assistance
a in general of the amounts made
available under subsection a
2 billion 207 million 561
294 dollars shall be for grants to
eligible recipients of sub-recipients
of funds under sub under sections 5307
or 5311 of title 49 united states code
that as a result of covet 19 require
additional assistance for costs related
to operations
personnel cleaning and sanitation
combating the spread of pathogens on
transit systems
and debt service payments incurred to
maintain operations and avoid layoffs
and furloughs
the administration funds made available
under subparagraph a
shall after allocation be administered
as if provided under paragraph one or
three as applicable
c application requirements one in
general the administrator of the federal
transit administration
may not allocate funds to an eligible
recipient or sub-recipient of funds
under chapter 53 of title 49 united
states code unless the recipient
provides to the administrator one
estimates a financial need to data on
reductions in farebox or other source
of local revenue for sustained
operations three a spending plan for
such funds and four demonstration of
expenditure of greater than ninety
percent of
funds available to the applicant from
funds made available
for similar activities in fiscal year
twenty twenty
two deadlines the administrator of the
federal transit administration xiao won
not later than 180 days after the date
of the enactment of this act issue a
notice of funding opportunity for
assistance under this paragraph and two
not later than 120 days after the
application deadline establishing in
notice of funding opportunity
under sub clause one make awards under
the paragraph to select applicants
three evaluation one in general
applications for assistance under this
paragraph shall be evaluated by the
administrator of the federal transit
administration
based on the level of financial need
demonstrated by an eligible recipient
or sub-recipient including projections
of future financial need
to maintain service as a percentage of
the 2018 operating costs
that has not been replaced by the funds
made available to eligible recipients or
sub-recipient
under paragraphs one through five of
this subsection when combined with an
amount
allocated to such eligible recipient or
sub-recipient from funds previously made
available
for the operating expenses of transit
agencies related to the response to the
covet 19
public health emergency
two restriction amounts made available
under this paragraph shall only be
available for operating expenses for
state applicants
state may apply for assistance under
this paragraph on behalf of an eligible
recipient
or sub-recipient or a group of eligible
recipients or sub-recipients
d unobligated funds if amounts made
available under this paragraph remained
unobligated on september 30th 2023
such amount shall be available for any
purpose eligible under section 5307 or
5311 of title 49 united states code
title 4 committee on homeland security
and governmental affairs section
4001 emergency federal employees leave
fund
a establishment appropriation there is
established in the treasury the
emergency federal employee leave fund in
the section referred to as
the fund to be administered by the
director of the office of personnel
management for the purpose set forth in
subsection b
in addition to the amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated for
fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
570 million dollars which shall be
deposited into the fund and remain
available through september 30
2022 the fund is available for
reasonable expenses incurred by the
office of personnel management
and administering this section be
purpose amounts in the fund shall be
available for reimbursement
to an agency for the use of paid leave
under this section by any employee of
the agency
who is unable to work because the
employee one is subject to federal state
or local quarantine or isolation
order related to covet 19. two has been
advised by a health care
provider to solve quarantine due to
concerns related to covet 19. three is
caring for an
individual who is subject to such an
order or has been so advised
or has experienced symptoms of covet 19
seeking a medical diagnosis
five is caring for a son or daughter of
such employee if the school or place of
care of the son or daughter has been
closed
if the school of such son or daughter
requires it or makes optional a virtual
learning instruction model
or requires or makes optional hybrid of
in-person virtual learning instruction
models
or the child care provider of such son
or daughter is unavailable
due to covet 19 precautions sixes
experience
any substantially similar condition
seven is caring for a family member
with a mental or physical disability or
who is 55 years of age or older and
incapable of self-care
without regard to whether another
individual other than the employee is
available to care for such family member
if the place of care for such family
member is closed or the direct not
available
leave under this section may only be
provided to and used by an employee
during the period beginning on the date
of the enactment of this act
and ending on september 30th 2021.
two total hours amount paid leave under
this section
a shall be provided to an employee in an
amount not to exceed 600 hours of paid
leave for each full-time employee
and in the case of a part-time employee
employee on an uncommon tour of duty
or in play with a seasonal work schedule
in an amount not to exceed the
proportional equivalent equivalent of
600 hours
to the extent amounts in the fund remain
available for reimbursement
b shall be paid at the same hourly rate
as other leave payments
and c may not be provided to an employee
if the leave will result in payments
greater than 20
800 in aggregate for any bi-weekly pay
period for a full-time employee or a
proportionately equivalent bi-weekly
limit
for a part-time employee three
relationship to other leave
paid leave under this section a is the
addition to any other lead provided to
an employee and b
may not be used by an employee
concurrently with any other paid leave
four calculation of retirement benefit
any paid leave provided to an employee
under this section shall reduce the
total service used to calculate any
federal
civilian retirement benefit
d employee defined in this section the
term employee means
one an individual in the executive
branch for whom annual and sick leave is
provided under
sub chapter 1 of chapter 63 of title 5
united states code
2 an individual employed by the united
states postal service
three an individual employed by the
postal regulatory commission
and four an employee of the public
defender service for the district of
columbia and the district of columbia
courts
section 4002 funding for the government
accountability office
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated for
fiscal year 2021 out of any money in the
treasury not otherwise appropriated
77 million dollars to remain available
until september 30th
2025 for necessary expenses of the
government accountability office to
prevent prepare for
and respond to coronavirus and to
support oversight of the coronavirus
response and the funds provided in this
act or any other act
pertaining to the coronavirus pandemic
section 4003 pandemic response
accountability committee funding
availability
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated for
fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
40 million dollars to remain available
until september 30th 2025
for the pandemic response accountability
committee to support oversight of the
coronavirus response
and of funds provided in this act or any
other act pertaining to the coronavirus
pandemic section 4004 funding for the
white house in addition to amounts
otherwise available
there is appropriated for fiscal year
2021 out of any money in the treasury
not otherwise appropriated twelve
million eight hundred thousand dollars
to remain available until september
thirtieth
twenty twenty one for necessary expenses
for the white house
to prevent prepare for and respond to
coronavirus
section 4005 federal emergency
management
agency appropriation in addition to
amounts otherwise available there is
appropriated to the federal emergency
management agency for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
50 billion dollars to remain available
until september 30th 2025
to carry out the purposes of the
disaster relief fund for costs
associated with major disaster
declarations
section 4006 funeral assistance a
in general for the emergency declaration
issued by the president on march 13
2020 pursuant to section 501b
of the robert t stafford disaster relief
and emergency assistance act
42 usc 5191b and for any subsequent
major disaster declaration
that supersedes such emergency
declaration the president shall provide
financial assistance to an individual or
household to meet disaster-related
funeral expenses under section
408 e1 of the robert t staff for
disaster relief and emergency assistance
act
42 usc 51741 for which the federal cost
share shall be 100
b use of funds funds appropriated under
section 4005 may be used to carry out
subsection a of this section
section 4007 emergency food and shelter
program
funding in addition to amounts otherwise
made available there is appropriated to
the federal emergency management
agency for fiscal year 2021 out of any
money in the treasury not otherwise
appropriated
400 million dollars to remain available
until september 30th 2025 for the
emergency food and shelter program
section 4008 humanitarian relief in
addition to amounts otherwise made
available there is appropriated to the
federal emergency management
agency for fiscal year 2021 out of any
money in the treasury not otherwise
appropriated
110 million dollars to remain available
until september 30th 2025
for the emergency food and shelter
program for the purposes of providing
humanitarian relief
to families and individuals encountered
by the department of homeland
security section 4009 cyber security and
infrastructure
security agency in addition to amounts
otherwise made available there is
appropriated for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
650 million dollars to remain available
until september 30th
2023 for the cyber security and
infrastructure security agency for cyber
security risk mitigation
section 4010 appropriation for the
united states digital service
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated for
fiscal year
2021 out of any money in the treasury
not otherwise appropriated
200 million dollars to remain available
until september 30th 2024
for the united states digital service
section 4011
appropriation for the technology
modernization fund
in addition to amounts otherwise
appropriated there is appropriated to
the general services administration for
fiscal year 2021 out of any money in the
treasury not otherwise appropriate
one billion dollars to remain available
until september 30th 2025
to carry out the purposes of the
technology modernization
fund section 4012
appropriation for the federal citizen
services fund
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
general services administration for
fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 150 million
dollars to remain available until
september 30th
2024 to carry out the purposes of the
federal citizen services fund
section 4013 afgh in the safer program
funding
in addition to amounts otherwise made
available appropriated to the federal
emergency management agency for fiscal
year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
300 million dollars to remain available
until september 30th 2025
of which 100 million shall be for
assistance to firefighters grants and
200 million
shall be for staffing for adequate fire
and emergency response grants
section 4014 emergency management
performance grant funding
in addition to amounts otherwise made
available there is appropriated to the
federal emergency management agency
fiscal year 2021 out of any money in the
treasury not otherwise appropriated
100 million dollars to remain available
until september 30th 2025 for emergency
management
performance grants total five committee
on small business and entrepreneurship
section 5001 modifications to paycheck
protection program a eligibility of
certain nonprofit entities for covered
loans for the paycheck protection
program
one in general section 7836 of the small
business act 15 usc
six as 636836 by the economic aid to
hard hit small business
non-profits and venues act title three
of division n of public law 116-260
is amended a in sub-paragraph a
one in clause 15 by striking and and at
the end
two and clause 16 by striking the period
at the end and inserting and
and three by adding at the end the
following
17 the term additional covered
non-profit entity
one means an organization described in
any paragraph of section 501 c of the
internal revenue code
of 1986 other than paragraph 3 4 6 or 19
and exempt from tax under 501a of such
code
2 does not include any entity that if
the entity were a business concern would
be described in section 121
120.110 of title 13
code of federal regulations or in any
successor
regulation or other related guidance or
rule that may be issued by the
administrator
other than a business concern described
in paragraph a
or k of such section and b in
subparagraph
d one and clause three by adding at the
end the following
three eligibility of certain
organizations subject to the provisions
in this subparagraph during the covered
period
aaa a non-profit organization shall be
eligible to receive a covered loan
if the nonprofit organization employs
not more than 500 employees
per physical location of the
organization in bb an additional covered
nonprofit entity in an organization that
b
for sub clauses 1dd and 2dd of causes
7 would be eligible for a covered loan
under clause 7
which i'll be eligible to receive a
covered loan if the entity or
organization employs not more than 300
employees
per physical location of the entity of
organization and two by adding at the
end the following
nine eligibility of additional covered
nonprofit entities
an additional covered nonprofit entity
shall be eligible to receive a covered
loan if
one the additional covered nonprofit
entity does not receive more than 15
percent of its recipients
from lobbying activities to the lowering
activities of the original
covered non-profit entity do not
compromise more than fifteen percent of
the total activities of the organization
three the cost of the lobbying
activities of the additional covered
non-profit entity
did not exceed one million dollars
during the most recent tax of
additional covered nonprofit entity that
ended prior to february 15
2020 and four the additional covered
nonprofit entity
employs not more than 300 employees two
eligibility for second draw loans
paragraph 37 a1 of section 7a of the
small business act 15 usc 636-a
as added by the economic aid to hard-hit
small businesses non-profits and venues
act title iii of division n of public
law
116-260 is amended by inserting
additional covered non-profit entity
after the terms
b eligibility of internet publishing
organizations
for covered loans under the pay
protection program
one in general section seven eight
thirty six d of
this act team usc six three six eight
three six
d as amended by subsection a is further
amended a and clause three by adding at
the end
following for eligibility of internet
publishing organizations a business
concern or other organization that was
not eligible to receive a covered loan
the day before the date of the enactment
of the sub-clause is assigned a north
american industry
classification system code of 51-9130
certifies in good faith as an internet
only news publisher or internet only
periodical publisher and is engaged in
the collection and distribution of local
or regional and national news
and information shall be eligible to
receive a covered loan for the continued
provision of news information content or
emergency information if
aaa the business concern organization
employs not more than 500 employees
or the size standard establishment by
the administrator for the north american
industry classification code
per physical location of the business
concern organization and bb
the business concern organization makes
a good faith certification
that proceeds of the loan will be used
to support expenses at the component of
the business
concern or organization that supports
local or regional news
b in clause 4 1 and sub clause 3 by
striking and
and at the end 2 and subclause 4 bb by
striking the period at the end and
inserting
colon and and three by adding at the end
the following
five any business concern or other
organization that was not eligible to
receive a covered loan the day before
the date of the enactment of this
sub-clause
is assigned a north american industry
classification system code
of 51913 certifies in good faith as an
internet only news publisher
or internet only periodical publisher
and is engaged in the collection and
distribution of local or regional and
national news and information
if the business concerner organization a
employs not more than 500 employees
or the size standard established by the
administrator for the north american
industry classification code
per physical location of the business
concern or organization
and bb is a majority owned or controlled
by business concern
organization that is assigned a north
american industry classification system
code of 51
9130 c in clause 5 by striking clause 3
2 4 4 or
7 and inserting sub clause 2 3 or 4
or clause 3 sub clause 4 or
5 or clause 4
clause 7 or clause 9 and d in clause
8 to 1 by striking business concern made
eligible by clause
3 2 or clause 4 4 of this paragraph and
inserting business concern made eligible
by subclause
2 or 4 or clause 3 or subclause 4 or 5
of clause 4
of this subparagraph and 2 by inserting
or organization after business concern
each place it appears 2 eligibility per
second
draw a loan section 7 8 37 a 4 2 of the
small business act
as amended by the economic aid to
hard-hit small businesses
non-profits and venues act title three
of division n of public law 116-260
is amended by striking clause 324
4 or 7 and inserting sub clause 2
3 or 4 or clause 3 sub clause 4
or 5 of clause 4 clause 7 or clause 9
c coordination with the continuation
coverage premium assistance
paycheck protection program section 7812
of the small business
act as redesignated transferred and
amended by section 304 b
of the economic aid to hard hit small
businesses
non-profits and venues act public law
116-260
is amended a by striking cares act or
inserting cares act and b by inserting
before the period at the end the
following
or premiums taking into account
determining the credit allowed under
section 6432 of the internal revenue
code of 1986.
two paycheck protection programs second
draw section 7837
j31 of the small business act as amended
by the economic aid to hard hit small
businesses
nonprofits and venues act title three of
division n of public law
116 260 is amended
a by striking or at the end of the item
a a
b by striking the period at the end of
item bb and
inserting or and c by adding at the end
the following
new item
[Music]
cc premiums taken into account in
determining the credit allowed
under section 6432 of the internal
revenue code
of 1986. three applicability
the amendments made by this subsection
shall apply only with respect to
applications for forgiveness of covered
loans
made under paragraphs 36 or 37 of
section 7a of the small business act
as amended by the economic aid to hard
hit small businesses non-profits and
venues act
title iii of division n of public law
116-260
that are received on or after the date
of enactment of this act
d commitment authority and
appropriations
one commitment authority section 1102 b1
of the cares act public law 116-136
is amended by striking 806 billion 450
million dollars in inserting 813 billion
700 million dollars
to direct appropriations in addition to
amounts otherwise available there is
appropriated to the administrator of the
small business administration for fiscal
year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
7 billion 250 million dollars to remain
available until expended for carrying
out this section
section 5002 targeted eidl advance
a definitions in this section one the
term administrator
means the administrator of the small
business administration and two the
terms covered entity and economic loss
have the meanings given the terms in
section 331a
of the economic aid to hard hit small
businesses non-profits and venues act
title 3 of division n of public law
116-260
b appropriations in addition to amounts
otherwise available there is
appropriated to the administrator for
fiscal year 2021 out of any money in the
treasury not otherwise appropriated
15 billion dollars one to remain
available until expended and two of
which the administrator shall use a
10 billion dollars to make payments to
covered entities
that have not received the full amounts
to which the covered entities are
entitled
under section 331 of the economic aid to
hard hit small businesses nonprofits and
venues act title 3 of division
n of public law 116-260 and b
five million dollars to make payments
under section one one one
zero e of the cares act 15 usc 9009 e
each of which shall be one made to a
covered entity that one has suffered an
economic loss of greater than 50 percent
and two employees not more than ten
employees two in an amount that is five
thousand dollars and
three with respect to the covered entity
to which the payment is made in addition
to any payment made
to the covered entity under section
1110e of the cares act
15 usc 9009e or section 331
of the economic aid to hard hit small
businesses nonprofits and venues act
title 3 of division n of public law
116-260
section 5003 support for restaurants
a definitions in this section one
administrator the administrator means
the administrator of the small business
administration
to affiliated business the term
affiliated business means a business in
which an eligible entity has an equity
or right to profit distributions of not
less than 50
or in which an eligible entity has the
contractual
authority to control the direction of
the business provided that such
affiliation shall be determined as of
any arrangements or agreements in
existence
as of march 13 2020
three covered period the term covered
period means the period a
beginning on february 15 2020 and b
ending on december 31 2021 or a date to
be determined by the administrator that
is not later than two years after the
date of enactment of this section
for eligible entity the term eligible
entity a
means a restaurant food stand food truck
food cart caterer saloon inn
tavern bar lounge brew pub tasting room
tap room
licensed facility or premise of a
beverage alcohol producer
where the public may taste sample or
purchase products
or other similar place of business in
which the public or patrons
assemble for the primary purpose of
being served food or drink
b and includes an entity described in
subparagraph a
that is located in an airport terminal
or that is tribally owned concern
and c does not include one an entity
described in subparagraph
a that one is a state or local
government operated business
two as of march 13 2020 owns or operates
together with any affiliated business
more than 20 locations regardless of
whether those locations do business
under the same or multiple names
or three has a pending application for
or has received a grant under section
324 of the economic aid hard hit small
businesses nonprofits and venues act
title iii of division n of public law
116-260
or 2 a publicly traded company 5.
exchange issuer security
the terms exchange issuer and security
have the meanings given
those terms in section 3a of the
securities exchange act of 1934
15 usc 78ca six fund
the term fund means the restaurant
revitalization fund established under
subsection b
seven pandemic related revenue loss the
term pandemic-related revenue loss means
with respect to an eligible entity a
except as provided in some paragraphs b
c and d the gross receipts as
established using such verification
documentation as the administrator may
require
of the eligible entity during 2020
subtracted from the gross receipts of
the eligible entity in 2019
if such sum is greater than zero
b if the eligible entity was not in
operation for the entirety of 2019
one the difference between one the
product obtained by multiplying the
average monthly gross receipts of the
eligible entity in 2019 by 12 and
two the product obtained by multiplying
the average monthly gross receipts of
the eligible entity
in 2020 by 12 or 2 an amount based on a
formula determined by the administrator
c if the eligible entity opened during
the period beginning on january 1 2020
and ending on the day before the date of
enactment of this section
one the expenses described in subsection
c
5a that were incurred by the eligible
entity minus any gross receipts received
or
to an amount based on a formula
determined by the administrator
or d if the eligible entity has not yet
opened as of the date of application for
a grant under subsection c but has
incurred expenses
described in subsection c5a as of the
date of enactment of the section
one the amount of those expenses or two
an amount based on a formula determined
by the administrator
for purposes of this paragraph the
pandemic related revenue losses for an
eligible entity
shall be reduced to any amounts received
from a covered loan
made under paragraph 36 or 37 of section
7a of the small business act
15 usc 636a in 2020 or 2021
eight payroll costs the term payroll
cost has the meaning given the term in
section 7836a of the small business act
15 usc 636
a36a except that such term shall not
include a
qualified wages as defined in subsection
c3 of section 2301
of the cares act taken into account in
determining the credit allowed under
such
section 2301 or b premiums taken into
account in determining the credit
allowed under section 6432 of the
internal revenue code of 1986
9 publicly traded company the term
publicly traded company means an entity
that is majority owned or controlled by
an entity that is an issuer
the securities of which are listed on a
national securities exchange under
section 6 of the securities exchange act
of 1934
15 usc 78 f 10
tribally owned concern the term tribally
owned concern
has the meaning given the term in
section 124.3
of title 13 code of federal regulations
or any successor regulation
b restaurant revitalization fund one in
general
there is established in the treasury of
the united states a fund to be known as
the restaurant revitalization fund
to appropriations a in general in
addition to amounts otherwise available
there is appropriated to the restaurant
revitalization fund for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
25 billion dollars to remain available
until expended
b distribution one in general of the
amounts made available under
sub-paragraph
a one five billion dollars shall be made
available to eligible entities with
gross receipts during 2019
not more than five hundred thousand
dollars and two
twenty billion dollars shall be
available to the administrator to award
grants under subsection c
in an equitable manner to eligible
entities of different sizes based on
annual gross receipts
two adjustments the administrator may
make adjustments
as necessary to the distribution of
funds under clause
one two based on demand and the relative
local costs in the market in which
eligible entities operate c grants after
initial period
notwithstanding sub-paragraph b on and
after
the date that is 60 days after the date
of enactment of the section or another
period of time determined by the
administrator
the administrator may make grants using
amounts appropriated under subparagraph
a to any eligible entity regardless of
the annual gross
receipt of the eligible entity three use
of funds
the administrator shall use amounts in
the fund to make grants described in
subsection c
c restaurant revitalization grants 1 in
general
except as provided in subsection b and
paragraph 3
the administrator shall award grants to
eligible entities
in the order in which applications are
received by the administrator
to application a certification an
eligible entity applying for a grant
under the subsection shall make a good
faith certification that one
the uncertainty of current economic
conditions makes
necessary the grant request to support
the ongoing operations of the eligible
entity
and two the eligible entity has not yet
applied for
or received a grant under section 324 of
the economic aid to hard hit small
businesses
nonprofits and venues act title iii of
division n
public law 116-260 b
business identifiers in accepting
applications for grants under this
subsection the administrator shall
prioritize the ability of each applicant
to use their existing business
identifiers
over requiring other forms of
registration or identification
that may not be common in their industry
and imposing additional burdens on
applicants
three priority and awarding grants a in
general
during the initial 21 day period in
which the administrator awards grants
under the subsection
the administrator shall prioritize
awarding grants to eligible entities
that are small business concerns
owned and controlled by women as defined
in section 3n of the small business act
15 usc 632n small business concerns
owned and controlled by veterans as
defined in section 3q
of such act 15 usc 632q
or socially and economically
disadvantaged small business concerns as
defined in section
8a 4a of the small business act 15
usc 637 a4a the administrator may
take such steps as necessary to ensure
that eligible entities described in this
sub-paragraph
have access to grant funding under this
section after the end of such 21-day
period
b certification for purposes of
establishing priority under
paragraph a an applicant shall submit a
self-certification of eligibility for
priority with the grant application
for grant amount a aggregate maximum
amount
the aggregate amount of grants made to
an eligible entity and
any affiliated businesses of the
eligible entity under the subsection 1
shall not exceed 10 million dollars and
2 shall be limited to 5 million
per physical location of the eligible
entity
b determination of grant amount
1 in general except as provided in this
paragraph the amount of a grant made to
an eligible entity under this subsection
shall be equal to the pandemic related
revenue loss of the eligible entity
to return to treasury any amount of a
grant made under the subsection to an
eligible entity based on estimated
receipts that is greater than the actual
gross receipts of the eligible entity in
2020 shall be returned to the treasury
five use of funds during the covered
period an eligible entity
that receives a grant under this
subsection may
use the grant funds for the following
expenses incurred as a direct result of
or during the coven 19 pandemic a
payroll cost b payment of principles or
interest on any mortgage obligation
which shall not include any prepayment
of principle on a mortgage obligation
c rent payments including rent under a
lease agreement which shall not include
any prepayment of rent d utilities
e-maintenance expenses including one
construction to accommodate outdoor
seating and two walls floors deck
surfaces furniture fixtures and
equipment
f supplies including protective
equipment and cleaning materials
g food and beverage expenses that are
within the scope of normal business
practice of the eligible entity before
the covered period
h covered supplier costs as defined in
section 7aa
of the small business act as
redesignated transferred and amended
by section 304b of the economic aid to
hard hit small businesses non-profits
and venues act
public law 116-260 i
operational expenses j paid sick leave
k any other expenses that the
administrator determines to be essential
to maintaining the eligible entity
six returning funds if an eligible
entity that receives a grant under the
subsection fails to use all grant funds
or permanently ceases operations on or
before the last day of the covered
period
the eligible entity shall return to the
treasury any funds
that the eligible entity did not use for
the allowable expenses under paragraph
five
section 5004 community navigator pilot
program a definitions in this section
one administration the term
administration means the small business
administration
to administrator the term administrator
means the administrator of the small
business administration
three community navigator services the
term community navigator services means
the outreach education and technical
assistance
provided by community navigators that
target eligible businesses to increase
awareness of and participation in
programs of the small business
administration for community navigator
the term community navigator means a
community organization
community financial institution as
defined in section 7a 36a of the small
business act 15 usc
636a36a or other private nonprofit
organization engaged in the delivery
of community navigator services five
eligible
business the term eligible business
means any small business concern with
priority for small business
concerns owned and controlled by women
as defined in section 3n of the small
business act
15 usc 632n small business concerns
owned and controlled by veterans
as defined in section 3q of such act 15
usc
632q and socially and economically
disadvantaged small business concerns
as defined in section 8 a 4a of the
small business act 15
usc 637 a4a 6 private nonprofit
organization
the term private nonprofit organization
means an entity that is described in
section 501c
of the internal revenue code of 1986 and
exempt from tax
under section 501a of such code 7
resource partner
the term resource partner means a a
small business development center as
defined in section 3 of the small
business act 15 usc
632 b a women's business center as
described in section 29 of the small
business act 15 usc
656 and see a chapter of the service
corps of retired executives
as defined in section 8b 1b of the act
15 usc 637 b1b
8. small business concern the term small
business concern has the meaning
given under section 3 of the small
business act 15
usc 632 9 state
the term state means a state of the
united states the district of columbia
the commonwealth of puerto rico the
virgin islands american samoa the
commonwealth of the northern mariana
islands and guam
or an agency instrumentality or fiscal
agent thereof
10 unit of general local government the
term unit of general local government
needs a county city town village or
other
general purpose political subdivision of
a state
b community navigator pilot program one
in general
the administrator of the small business
administration shall establish a
community navigator pilot program
to make grants to and or enter into
contracts or cooperative agreements with
private nonprofit organizations
resource partners states tribes and
units of local government to ensure the
delivery of free community navigator
services
to current or prospective owners of
eligible businesses in order to improve
access to assistance programs
and resources made available because of
the coven 19 pandemic
by federal state tribal and local
entities
to appropriations in addition to amounts
otherwise available
there is appropriated to the
administrator for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 100 million
dollars to remain available until
september 30 2022 for carrying out this
subsection
see outreach and education one promotion
the administrator shall develop and
implement a program
to promote community navigator services
to current or prospective owners of
eligible businesses
two call center the administrator shall
establish a telephone hotline to offer
information about federal programs
to assist eligible businesses and offer
referral services to resource
partners community navigators potential
lenders and other persons that the
administrator determines appropriate for
current or prospective owners of
eligible businesses
three outreach the administrator shall a
conduct outreach and education in the 10
most commonly spoken languages in the
united states
to current or prospective owners of
eligible businesses on community
navigator services and other federal
programs to assist eligible businesses
b improve the website of the
administration to describe such
community
navigator services and other federal
programs and see implement an education
campaign
by advertising in media targeted to
current or prospective owners of
eligible businesses
for appropriations in addition to
amounts otherwise available there is
appropriated to the administrator for
fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
75 million dollars to remain available
until september 30
2022 for carrying out the subsection d
sunset
the authority of the administrator to
make grants under the sections shall
terminate on december 31
2025. section 5005
shuttered venue operators a in general
in addition to amounts otherwise
available
there is appropriated for fiscal year
2021 out of any money in the treasury
not otherwise appropriated
1 billion 250 million dollars to remain
available until expended to carry out
section
324 of the economic aid to hard hit
small businesses non-profits and venues
act
title three of division n of public law
116-260
of which five hundred thousand dollars
shall be used to provide technical
assistance to help applicants access the
system for award management
or any successor there to or to assist
applicants with an alternative
grant application system
the reduction of shuttered venues
assistance for new ppp recipients
section 324 of the economic aid to hard
hit small businesses
non-profits and venues act title iii of
division n a public law 116-260 is
amended one
in subsection a1a6a by striking
subclause 3
b by redesignating subclause 4 as
subclass 3
and c in sub clause 3 also redesignated
by striking subclauses 1 2 and 3
and inserting subclauses 1 and 2 and 2
in subsection c1 thank you
a and sub-paragraph a in a matter of
preceding clause one by striking a grant
and inserting subject to
sub-paragraphs b and c a grant and b
by adding at the end the following c
reduction for recipients of new ppp
loans one in general the otherwise
applicable amount of a grant under
subsection b2 to an eligible person or
entity shall be reduced by the total
amount of loans guaranteed under
paragraph 36 or 37
of section 7a of the small business act
15 usc 636a that are received on or
after december 27 2020 by the eligible
person or entity
to application to governmental entities
for purposes of applying one to an
eligible person or entity owned by a
state or a political
subdivision of a state the relevant
entity
one shall be the eligible person or
entity
and two should not include entities of
the state or political subdivision other
than the eligible person or entity
section 5006 direct appropriations in
general
addition to amounts otherwise available
there is appropriated to the
administrator for fiscal year 2021 out
of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
to remain available until expended one
840
million dollars for administrative
expenses including to prevent prepare
for and respond to the coca-19 pandemic
domestically or internationally
including administrative expenses
related to subparagraphs 36 and 737
of section 7a of the small business act
section 324 of the economic aid to hard
hit small businesses nonprofits
and venues act title 3 division in of
public law 116-260
section 5002 of this title and section
5003 of this title
and two 460 million dollars to carry out
the disaster loan program authorized by
section 7b of the small business act 15
usc
636b of which 70 million shall be
for the cost of direct loans authorized
by such section and 390 million dollars
shall be for administrative expenses to
carry out such program b
inspector general in addition to amounts
otherwise available there is
appropriated to the inspector general of
the small business administration for
fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 25
million dollars to remain available
until expended for necessary expenses of
the inspector
office of inspector general title vi
committee on environment and public
works section 6001 economic adjustment
assistance a
economic development administration
appropriation in addition to amounts
otherwise available there is
appropriated for fiscal year 2021 out of
any money in the treasury
not otherwise appropriated three billion
dollars to remain available until
september 30 2022
to the department of commerce for
economic adjustment assistance as
authorized by sections 209 and 703
of the public works and economic
development act of 1965
42 usc 3149 and 3233 to prevent perform
respond to coronavirus
and for necessary answers for responding
to atomic injury as a result
virus we have the fun provided for this
section up to two percent shall be used
for federal costs to administer such
assistance utilizing temporary federal
personnel
as may be necessary consistent with the
requirements applicable to such
administrative funding in fiscal year
2020 to prevent prepare for
and respond to coronavirus then which
shall remain available until september
30 2027.
see of the funds provided by this
section 25 shall be for assistance to
states and communities
that have suffered economic injury as a
result of job and gross domestic product
losses in the travel tourism or outdoor
recreation sectors
section 6002 funding for pollution and
disparate impacts of the cobia 19
pandemic a
in general in addition to amounts
otherwise available there is
appropriated to the environmental
protection agency for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 100 million
dollars to remain available until
expended
to address health outcome disparities
from pollution of the coca-19 pandemic
of which 150 million shall be for grants
contracts and other agency
activities that identify and address
disproportionate environmental or public
health harms and risks and minority
populations are low income populations
under a section 103b of the clean air
act 42 usc 7403 b
b section 1442 of the safe drinking
water act 42 usc
300 dash one
see section 104 k 7a of the
comprehensive environmental response
compensation and liability act of 1980
42 usc
9604 k7a and d section 791 through 797
and the environmental
policy act of 2005 42 usc 161 31 through
16137
and two 50 million dollars shall be for
grants and activities authorized under
subsections a through c
of section 103 of the clean air act 42
usc 7403
and grants and activities authorized
under section 105 of such act 42 usc
7405
b administration of funds one of the
funds made available pursuant to
subsection a one of the administrators
shall reserve two percent of
administrative costs necessary to carry
out activities funded pursuant to such
subsection two of the funds made
available pursuant to section
subsection a2 the administration
administrator shall reserve five percent
for activities funded pursuant to
subsection other than grants section
6003
united states fish and wildlife service
a inspection interdiction and research
related to certain species in cobit 19.
in addition to amounts otherwise made
available there is appropriate fiscal
year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 95 million
dollars to remain available until
expended to carry out the provisions of
the
fish and wildlife act of 1956 16 usc
742a
and the fish and wildlife coordination
act 16 usc 661 through direct
expenditure contracts and grants of
which
one 20 million dollars shall be for
wildlife
inspections and addictions
investigations and related activities
and for
efforts to address wildlife trafficking
to 30 million
shall be for the care of captive species
listed under the endangered species act
of 1973
and for the care of rescued and
confiscated wildlife and for the care of
federal trust species and facilities
experiencing lost revenues due to cover
19
and 3 45 million shelby for research and
extension activities to strengthen early
detection
rapid response and science-based
management to address wildlife disease
outbreaks before they become pandemics
and strengthen capacity for wildlife
health monitoring to enhance early
detection of diseases that have the
capacity to jump the species barrier
and pose a risk in the united states
including the development of a national
wildlife disease database
b lacey act provisions in addition to
amounts otherwise made available
there is appropriated for fiscal year
2021 out of any money in the treasury
not otherwise appropriated 10 million
dollars to remain available until
expended
to carry out the provisions of section
42a of title 18 united states code and
the lacie act amendments
of 1981 16 usc 3371-3378 to identify and
designate wildlife species or larger
taxonomic
groups of species as injurious under
such provisions if they transmit a
pathogen that could potentially pose a
risk to human health and
develop regulations to develop a process
to make emergency listings for injurious
species
title 7 committee on commerce science
and transportation subtitle a
transportation and infrastructure
section 7101 grants to the national
railroad passenger corporation a
northeast corridor appropriation in
addition to amounts otherwise available
there is appropriated for fiscal year
2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 970 million 388
160 to remain available until september
30 2024 for grants as
authorized under section 11101a of the
fast act public law 114-94 to prevent
prepare for
and respond to coronavirus b national
network appropriation in addition to
amounts otherwise available there is
appropriated for fiscal year 2021 out of
any money in the treasury
not otherwise appropriated 729 million
six hundred and eleven
thousand eight hundred forty dollars to
remain available until september thirty
two thousand twenty four for grant says
authorized under section 11101b
of the fast act public law 114-94 to
prevent
prepare for and respond to coronavirus c
long-distance service restoration and
employee recalls not less than
165 million 926 thousand dollars of the
aggregate amounts made available under
subsections a and b
shall be for use by the national
railroad passenger corporation to one
restore
not later than 90 days after the date of
enactment of this act the frequency of
rail services long distance routes
as defined in section 24102 of title 49
united states code
that the national railroad passenger
corporation reduced the frequency
of honor after july 1 2020 and continue
to operate such service at such
frequency and to recall and manage
employees furloughed on or after october
1 2020
as a result of efforts to prevent
prepare for and respond to coronavirus
d use of funds in lieu of capital
payments not less than 109 million 805
000
of the aggregate amounts made available
under subsections a and b one
shall be used shall be for the use of by
the national railroad passenger
corporation in lieu of capital payments
from states and commuter rail
passenger transportation providers that
are subject to the cost allocation
policy under section 24905c of title 49
united states code
and two not withstanding sections 24319g
and 24905 c1a1 of title 49 united states
code
such amounts do not constitute
cross-subsidization of
commuter rail passenger transportation e
use of funds for state payments for
state supported routes
one in general of the amounts made
available under subsection b
174 million 850 000 shall be
for use by the national railroad
passenger corporation to offset amounts
required to be paid by states but
for covered state supported routes to
funding share
the share of funding provided under
paragraph one with respect to covered
state supported routes shall be
distributed as follows
a each covered state-supported route
shall receive seven percent of the costs
allocated to the route
in fiscal year 2019 under the cost out
allocation methodology adopted pursuant
to section 209 of the passenger rail
investment improvement act of 2008
o'clock 1 1 0-432 b
any remaining amounts under the
distribution described in sub-paragraph
a shall be a portion to each covered
state supported route in proportion
to the passenger revenue of such route
and other revenue allocated
to such route in fiscal year 2019
divided by the total passenger revenue
and other revenue allocated to all
covered
state supported routes in fiscal year
2019 three
covered state supported route defined in
this subsection the term covered state
supported route means a state-supported
route
as such term is defined in section 24102
of title 49 united states code but does
not include a state-supported route for
which service was terminated on or
before february 1
2020. f use of funds for debt repayment
or prepayment not more than 100 million
885 thousand dollars of the aggregate
amount
made available under subsections a and b
shall be one for the repayment or
prepayment of debt incurred by the
national railroad passenger corporation
under
financing arrangements entered into
prior to the date of enactment of this
act and two to
pay required reserves costs and fees
related to such debt including for loans
from the department of transportation
loans that would otherwise
have been paid from national railroad
passenger corporation revenues
g project management oversight not more
than two million dollars of the accurate
amounts made available under subsections
a and b shall be for activities
authorized under sections
11101c of the fast act public law 114-94
section 7102 relief for airports a in
general
one in general in addition to amounts
otherwise available there is
appropriated for fiscal year 2021 out of
any funds in the treasury
not otherwise appropriated eight billion
dollars to remain available until
september 30 2024 for assistance to
sponsor
sponsors of airports as such terms are
defined in section
47102 of title 49 united states code to
be made available to prevent prepare for
and respond to coronavirus two
requirements and limitations
amounts made available under this
section a may not be used for
any purpose not directly related to the
airport and b may not be provided to any
airport that was allocated in excess of
four years of operating funds to prevent
prepare for
and respond to proporano virus in fiscal
year 2020.
b allocations the following term shall
apply to the amounts made
available under this section one
operating expenses and debt service
payment
a in general not more than 6 billion 492
million
shall be made available for primary
airports as such term is defined in
section 47102 of title 49 united states
code
and certain cargo airports for costs
related to operations personnel cleaning
sanitation janitorial services
combating the spread of pathogens at the
airport and debt service payments fee
distribution amounts made available
under this paragraph one should not be
subject to the reduced apportionments
under section 47114f
of title 49 united states code 2 shall
risk be apportioned as set forth in
sections
one one four c one a four seven one one
four c one c one
four seven one one four c one c two four
seven one one four c
two a four seven one one four c two b
and four seven one one four c two e of
title forty nine united states code and
three
should not be subject to a maximum
apportionment limits set forth in
section 47114 c1b
of title 49 united states code c
remaining amounts any amount remaining
after distribution under said paragraph
b shall be distributed to the sponsor of
each primary airport
a such term is defined in section 47102
of title 49 united states code
based on each such primary airport's
passenger employments
compared to the total passenger
employments of all such primary
airports in calendar year 2019.
to federal share for development
projects a in general not more than
608 million dollars allocated under
subsection a1 shall be
available to pay a federal share of 100
of the costs for any grant awarded in
fiscal year 2021
or in fiscal year 2020 with less than
100 percent federal share for an airport
development project
as such term is defined in section 47102
of title 49
b remaining amounts any amount remain
remaining under this paragraph
shall be distributed as described in
paragraph one c
three non-primary airports a in general
not more than one hundred million
dollars shall be made available for
general aviation and commercial service
airports that are not primary airports
as such terms are defined in section
47102 of title 49 united states code for
costs related to operations personnel
cleaning sanitation janitorial services
combating the spread of pathogens at the
airport and debt service payments
b distribution amounts made available
under this paragraph shall be a portion
to each non-primary airport based on the
categories published in the most current
national plan of integrated airport
systems
reflecting the percentage of the
aggregate published eligible
development costs upset for each such
category and then dividing the allocated
funds evenly among the airport
eligible airports in such category
rounding up to the nearest thousand
dollars c
remaining amounts any amount remaining
under this paragraph shall be
distributed as described in paragraph 1c
for airport concessions a in general not
more than 800 million dollars shall be
made available
for sponsors of primary airports to
provide relief from rent and minimum
annual guarantees to airport concessions
of which at least 640 million dollars
shall be made available to provide
relief to eligible small airport
concessions and of which at least 160
million dollars shall be available to
provide relief to eligible large airport
concessions located at primary airports
b distribution the amounts made
available for each set aside in this
paragraph shall be distributed to the
sponsor of each primary airport as such
term is defined in section 47102 of
title 49 united states code
based on each such primary airport's
passenger emplainments compared to the
total passenger employments of all such
primary airports
in calendar year 2019. see conditions as
a condition of approving a grant under
this paragraph one the sponsor shall
provide such
relief from the date of enactment of
this act until the sponsor has provided
relief
equaling the total grant amount to the
extent practicable and to the extent
permissible under state laws local laws
and applicable trust indentures
and two for each set-aside the sponsor
shall provide relief from rent and
minimum
annual guarantee obligations to each
eligible airport concession
in an amount that reflects each eligible
airport concession's proportional share
of the total amount of the rent minimum
annual guarantees of those
eligible airport concessions at such
airport c administration one
administrative expenses
the administrator the federal aviation
administration may retain up to 0.1
percent of the funds provided under this
section
to fund the award of an oversight by the
administrator of grants made under this
section
two workforce retention requirements a
required retention
as a condition for receiving funds
provided under this section
an airport shall continue to employ
through september 30 2021 at least 90
percent of the number of individuals
employed
after making adjustments for retirements
or voluntary employee
separations by the airport as of march
27 2020
the waiver of retention requirement the
secretary shall waive the
workforce retention requirement at the
secretary determines that one the
airport has experienced economic
harnship
as a direct result of the requirement or
two the requirement reduces aviation
safety or security c
exception the workforce retention
requirement shall not apply to non-hub
airports or prime non-primary
airports receiving funds under this
section d
non-compliance any financial assistance
provided under this section to an
airport that fails to comply with the
workforce retention requirement
described in subparagraph
a and does not otherwise qualify for a
waiver exception under this paragraph
shall be subject to clawback
by the secretary d definitions in this
section
one eligible large airport concession
the term eligible large airport
concession means a concession as defined
in section 2 3.3 of title 49
code of federal regulations that is in
terminal and has maximum gross receipts
averaged over the previous three fiscal
years of more than
56 million 420 000 to eligible small
airport concession
the term eligible small airport
concession means a concession as defined
in section 23.3 of title 49
code of federal regulations that is in
terminal and a a small business
with maximum gross receipts averaged
over the previous three fiscal years
of less than 56 million four hundred
twenty thousand
dollars or b is a joint venture as
defined in section 23.3 of title 49 code
of federal regulations
section 7103 emergency faa employee
leave fund a establishment
appropriation there was established in
the federal aviation administration the
emergency faa employee leave fund in
this section referred to as the fund
to be administered by the administrator
of the federal aviation administration
for the purposes set forth in subsection
b
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there was appropriated for
fiscal year 2021 out of any money in the
treasury not otherwise appropriated
nine million dollars which shall be
deposited into the fund and remain
available through september 30 2022.
be purpose amounts in the fund shall be
available to the administrator for the
use of paid leave under
this section by any employee of the
administration who is unable to work
because the employee won
is subject to a federal state or local
quarantine or isolation order related to
cobit 19
2 has been advised by a health care
provider to self warranty due to
concerns related to covet 19
three is caring for an individual who is
subject to such an order or has so been
advised
four is experiencing symptoms of coca-19
and seeking a medical diagnosis
five is caring for a son or daughter of
such employee at the school or place of
care of the son or daughter has been
closed
if the school of such son or daughter
requires or makes optional
virtual learning instruction model or
requires or makes optional a hybrid or
in-person
and individual learning instruction
models or the child care provider of
such son or daughter is unavailable due
to cover 19 precautions
six is experiencing any other
substantially similar conditions seven
is caring for a family member
with a mental or physical disability who
is 55 years of age or older and
incapable of self-care
without regard to whether another
individual other than the employee is
available to care for such
family member if the place of care for
such family members closed or the direct
care provider is unavailable due to
cobit 19
or 8 is obtaining immunization related
to covet 19
or is recovering from an injury
disability illness or condition related
to such immunization
through c limitations one period of
availability
paid leave under this section may be
only be provided to and used by an
employee of the administration during
the period beginning on the date of
enactment of this section
and ending on september 30 2021 two
total hours amount
paid leave under this section a shall be
provided to an employee of the
administration
in an amount not to exceed 600 hours of
paid leave for each
full-time employee and in the case of a
part-time employee employee
on an uncommon tour of duty or employee
with a seasonal work schedule
an amount not to exceed the proportional
equivalent of 600 hours to the extent
amounts in the fund remain available for
reimbursement b shall be paid at the
same hourly rate as other legal payments
and c
may not be provided to an employee if
the lead would result in payments
greater than two hundred eighty
two thousand eight hundred dollars in
aggregate for any bi-weekly pay period
for a full-time employee
or proportionally equivalent bi-weekly
limit for a part-time employee
see relationship gender leave paid leave
under this section
a is in addition to any other leave
provided to an employee of the
administration and b
may not be used by employee
administration concurrently with any
other paid leave
four calculation of retirement benefit
any paid leave
provided to an employee of the
administration in this section shall
reduce the total service
used to calculate any federal civilian
retirement benefit
section 7104 emergency tsa employment
employee leave fund a establishment
appropriation there was established in
the
transportation security administration
in this section referred to as the
administration
the emergency tsa employee lee fund in
this section referred to as the fund
to be administered by the administrator
of the administration for the purposes
set forth in subsection b
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated for
fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated 13 million
dollars which shall be deposited into
the fund
and remain available through september
30 2022
purpose b purpose amounts in the fund
shall be available to the administration
for the use of paid leave under this
section by any employee of the
administration
who is unable to work because the
employee one is subject to a federal
state or local quarantine or isolation
order
related to covet 19.
two has been advised by health care
provider to self-quarantine due to
concerns related to covid19
3 is caring for an individual who's
subject to such an order or has been so
advised for
is experiencing symptoms of coca-19
seeking a medical diagnosis
five is caring for a son or daughter or
such employee if the school or place of
care of the son or daughter has been
closed
if the school such son or daughter
requires or makes a virtual
an optional virtual learning instruction
model requires or makes
optional a hybrid of in-person and
virtual learning instruction models
or the child care provider such son or
daughter is unavailable due to covenant
19 precautions
six is experiencing any other
substantially similar condition
seven is caring for a family member with
a mental or physical disability who
is 55 years of age or older and
incapable of self-care without regard to
whether another individual other than
the employee
is available to care for such family
member if the place of care of such
family members closed
or the direct care provider is unable to
enable unavailable due to cover 19 or 8
is obtaining immunization related to
covered 19 or is recovering from any
injury
disability illness or condition related
to such immunization
c limitations one period availability
paid leave under the section may only be
provided to and used by an employee of
the administration during the period
beginning
on the date of enactment of this section
and ending on september 30th 2021
2 total hours amount paid leave under
the section a
shall be provided to an employee of the
administration in an amount not to
exceed 600 hours of paid leave
for each full-time employee and in the
case of a part-time employee employees
on a common tour of duty or employee
within a seasonal work schedule
in an amount not to exceed the
proportional equivalent of 600 hours
to the extent amounts in the fund remain
available for reimbursement
b shall be paid at the same hourly rate
as other lead payments and c
may not be provided to an employee if
the leave would result in payments
greater than 2800
in aggregate for any bi-weekly pay
period for a full-time employee
or proportionately equivalent by weekly
limit for a part-time employee
three relationship to other leave paid
leave under the section
a is in addition to any other leave
provided to an employee of the
administration and
b may not be used by an employee of the
administration concurrently with any
other paid leave
four calculation of retirement benefit
any paid leave provided
to an employee of the administration
under this section shall reduce the
total service used to calculate any
federal civilian retirement benefit
subtitle b aviation manufacturing jobs
protection
section 7201 definitions in the subtitle
one eligible employee group the term
eligible employee group means the
portion of the employees
united states workforce that a does not
exceed 25
of the employers total united states
workforce as of april 1st 2020 and b
contains only employees with a total
compensation level of 200 000
or less per year and c is engaged in
aviation manufacturing activities and
services or maintenance repair and
overhaul activities and services
two aviation manufacturing company the
term aviation manufacturing company
means a corporation firm or other
business entity
a that one actively manufactures an
aircraft
aircraft engine propeller or a component
part or systems of an aircraft or
aircraft engine
under federal aviation administration
production approval two
halter certificate issued under part 145
of title 14 code of federal regulations
for maintenance repair and overhaul of
aircraft aircraft engines components or
propellers or three operates a process
certified to
sae as9100 related to the design
development or provision of an aviation
product or service including a part
component or assembly
b which is one is established created
organ organized in the united states or
under the laws of the united states and
two
has significant operations in a majority
of its employees engaged in aviation
manufacturing activities and services or
maintenance repair
and overhaul activities and services
based in the united states
c which has involuntary furloughed or
laid off at least 10 percent of its
workforce in 2020 is compared to 2019
or has experienced at least 15 percent
decline in 2020 revenues as compared to
2019
d that as supported by sworn financial
statements or other appropriate data
has identified the eligible employee
group and the amount of total
compensation level for the eligible
employee group
e that agrees to provide private
contributions and maintain the total
compensation level for the eligible
employee group for the duration of an
agreement under the subtitle
f that agrees to provide immediate
notice and justification to the
secretary
of involuntary furloughs or layoffs
exceeding 10 of the workforce that is
not included in an eligible employee
group
for the duration of an agreement and
receipt of public contributions under
the subtitle g
that has not conducted involuntary
furloughs or reduced pay rates or
benefits for the eligible employee group
subject to the employer's rights
to discipline or terminate an employee
in accordance with employer policy
between the date of application the date
on which
a corporation form or other business
entity enters into an agreement with the
secretary under the subtitle in h
that one in the case of a corporation
form or other business entity including
any parent company or
subsidiary subsidiary of a corporation
firm or other business entity that holds
any type of production certification
certificate or similar authorization
issued under section 44704 of title 49
united states code
with respect to a transport category
airplane covered under part 25 of title
14 cold
code of federal regulations certified
certificated with passenger seating
capacity of 50 or more agrees to refrain
from conducting an involuntary layoffs
or furloughs
or reducing pay rates and benefits for
the eligible employee group
subject to the employer's right to
discipline or terminate the employee in
accordance with employer policy from the
date of agreement until september 30th
2021
or the duration of the agreement and
receipt of public contributions under
the subtitle whichever period ends later
or two
in the case of corporation firm or other
business entity not specified under
sub-paragraph one agrees to refrain from
conducting involuntary layoffs
or furloughs or reducing pay rates and
benefits for eligible employee group
subject to the employer's right to
discipline or terminate an employee
in accordance with employer policy for
the duration of the agreement
and receipt of public contributions
under this title
three employee the chairman employee has
a meeting given that
that term in section three of the fair
labor standards act of 1938
29 us uc 203
for employer the term employer means an
aviation manufacturing company
that is an employer is defined in
section three a fair labor standard act
of 1930
29 uc 203 five
private contribution the term private
contribution means the contribution
funded by the employer under
this subtitle to maintain 50 of the
eligible employee group's total
compensation level
and combined with the public
contribution is sufficient to mean the
total compensation level for the
eligible employee group
as of april 1st 2020. six public
contribution
the term public contribution means the
contribution funded by the federal
government under the subtitle to provide
50 of the eligible employees group's
total
compensation level and combined with
private contribution is sufficient to
maintain the total compensation level
for those in the eligible employee group
as a people first 2020.
seven secretary the term secretary means
the secretary of transportation
eight total compensation level the term
total compensation level means the level
of total base compensation
and benefits provided to an eligible
employee group employee
excluding overtime and premium paying
excluding any federal state or local
payroll taxes paid as a
as of april 1st 2020. section
7202 payroll support program a in
general the secretary shall establish a
payroll support program and enter into
agreements with employers
who have met the eligibility criteria
specified in subsection b
and are not ineligible under subsection
c to provide public
contributions to supplement compensation
of an eligible employee group
there is appropriated there is
appropriated for fiscal year 2021 out of
amounts in the treasury otherwise
appropriated
three billion dollars to remain
available until september 30th 2023
for secretary to carry out the payroll
support program authorized under the
preceding sentence for which one percent
of the funds may be used for
implementation costs
and administrative expenses b
eligibility the secretary shall enter in
into an agreement provide public
contributions for a term no longer than
six months solely with an employer that
agrees
to use the funds received under an
agreement exclusively for the
continuation
of employee wages salaries and benefits
to maintain the total compensation level
for the eligible employee group as of
april 1st 2020
the duration of the agreement and to
facilitate the retention require recall
employees of the employer except that
such funds may not be used for back pay
of retire returning
rehired or recalled employees c
ineligibility
the secretary may not enter in into any
agreement under the section with an
employer who was allowed a credit under
section 2301 of the cares act 26 usc
311 note for them immediately preceding
calendar quarter ending before such
agreement is entered into
who received financial assistance under
section 41113
of the cares act 15 usc 9073 or who is
currently
expending financial assistance under the
paycheck protection program established
intersection
you